the esteemed Doctor Thomas morstead
entered the cell of the anomaly he'd
been warned and even chastised by his
colleagues but who in the foundation
could tell him what to do he was the
best at what he did maybe the greatest
in the whole history of the
foundation as he entered the room SCP
049 bid him welcome cordial as always so
in fact that you'd never guess you were
talking to a killer Dr morstead knew the
truth of what he was dealing with but he
also believed he could get through to
049 calm him exercise the devil from him
it was the meeting of two great minds
one of them human one of them part human
part something that has never been clear
it was to be a battle of wits and like
so many great battles this one would
turn into a massacre before we get to
that faithful meeting there are some
things you should know about the anomaly
known as SCP 049 if you saw him in the
street the first thing you think of is
playing because 049 always looked the
same a man dressed in black robes with a
plague doctor's mask but this wasn't a
costume that could be taken off in fact
it wasn't a costume at all it was him
the robes had grown out of him like an
exoskeleton that horrible mask with the
pointed nose wasn't covering his face it
was his face a kind of shell that had
seemingly sprouted from bone the first
reports came during World War II in a
picturesque town in the south of France
called montal people had begun going
missing children disappeared from their
beds in the middle of the night and
weren't seen again adults went to the
market and never returned local
authorities searched high and low they
scoured nearby woods and dragged the
rivers but nothing was found because
what was happening wasn't Criminal there
was no clue they could stumble upon or
eyewitness who would break the cave
no this was something else something
that the town's folk could never
understand word spread and that's when a
search in Discovery team was sent from
the foundation it was a cold Dark Night
in January of 1941 when the team found
what they were looking for they walked
through the open door of a small house
located not too far from the grand
chatau deu to find a mass man sitting
next to an open fire and he wasn't alone
the floor around him looked like it was
moving upon closer inspection the team
saw that the floor was covered with ring
grasping bodies it's patience as it
called them
bwa said the thing welcome to my home
those so-called patients crawled towards
the team intented seemed to cause harm
the hostiles now known as SCP
049-2 were deemed dangerous and had to
be eliminated a site it seemed that
didn't bother 049 in the slightest it
just sat there occasionally looking up
for from writing notes in a leatherbound
book as his patients were gunned down
once the Carnage ended it simply closed
its book stood up and allowed itself to
be escorted away and that's the story of
how 049 ended up at the facility
becoming a guest of sorts staying in a
standard secure humanoid containment
cell research sector 02 site 19 the few
that came into contact with 049 remarks
that it was a pleasure for them with its
impeccable manners vast knowledge of
medicine and human anatomy Sharp and
stinging W they almost became Spellbound
listening to it caught in the throws of
its charms until with the Simple Touch
of its hand it would drain the life from
them that's why SCP 049 was classified
as a uclid that's why armed guards were
always stationed outside itself cell
it's why doctors took great precautions
when in its presence and it's why Dr
morstead should have known better
remember when 049 was discovered in
France it willingly went with the team
like it was happy it had been found as
if it had planned its own capture when
it arrived at the facility it didn't act
like it was contained against its will
it was like it was returning home
initial findings as to the biology of
049 were that it didn't require any
sustenance at all not even water it
seemed content to be left alone with its
notebooks it did not object when it was
asked if it could share some of its
notes and gladly handed over its
journals but upon examination it was
discovered that they were written in the
language that no linguist or
cryptologist has so far been able to
translate it's apparent that 049 derives
much satisfaction from seeing so-called
experts struggle over its text unable to
read those notes a long line of doctors
visited 049 in itself cell each
fascinated by what they beheld it was
learned that it has traveled the globe
it speaks many languages but prefers to
speak what it calls Le long de French it
asks for only one thing warm-blooded
animals the facility agreed to supply
049 with various kinds including rabbits
cat battle and even an ape on one
occasion just like with humans it could
kill the animals with a mere Touch of
its hand sucking the life right out of
them but that wasn't even the most
incredible part soon those animals would
rise again as if reanimated by 049 they
would become for all intents and
purposes the Living Dead and they were
hostile after several unfortunate
incidents they were taken from the cell
the moment they arose and disposed of in
the incinerator this was not to the
liking of zero for nine who would claim
it had cured the animals for it the
world was sick it saw plague and
pestilence everywhere and the meaning of
its existance was to rid the world of
disease humans it said contained a virus
and had to be cleansed in the first days
after arriving at the facility 049
didn't seem to pose a threat to humans
it was quite friendly in fact it seemed
aware of the fear it caused in staff and
would often go out of its way to make
them feel comfortable and safe this was
a rude of course or a Canard as 049
likeed to say it had no intention to
help humans no it had come for humans it
wasn't trapped it had set a trap one of
the first people to truly upset 049 was
Dr Raymond Ham a well-respected
physician that had twice been a
contender for the Nobel Prize for his
more mainstream work what had confused
Dr Ham the most was not 049 clothed like
exoskeleton or even his ability to
reanimate the dead but the bag that it
used zer 49 was somehow able to pull a
seemingly endless supply of surgical
tools from that bag sometimes it would
even pull out objects that Were Somehow
larger than the bag itself it was as if
the bag connected to somewhere else and
that's what Dr Ham wanted to talk about
on that fateful day with 049 on one side
of the cell and Dr Ham on the other he
asked how is it that you can produce a
great quantity of tools from that bag
I've observed you and it seems to me
that you are doing The Impossible dear
doctor replied 049 The Scourge The Great
dying cannot be fought with a handful of
toys my bag is merely the product of my
imagination it gives me what I require
you dear sir it seems are limited by
your imagination it stopped for a second
or two and stared at Dr Ham I detect you
are unwell it said in a voice not as
amiable as before it's just a cold said
the doctor ah just a cold if you had
seen what I have seen you you would not
utter such insulting words Dr Ham pulled
out some papers from a briefcase and
approached 049 holding them close enough
so it could read them you see said Dr
Ham pointing to the results on the paper
those animals you say you cured they
were not diseased they were perfectly
healthy before they died and your
so-called cure it turned them into
something quite terrible we found that
if they were left alone they began to
eat each other and then themselves 049
did not respond and after a brief pause
said only a good day to your doctor
please close the door on your way out
you should get some rest ham refused to
go and instead turned the conversation
to this real interest the bag demanding
that 049 let him see inside of it very
well doctor 049 said in private 049
began to pull a series of long metal
poles out of its bag followed by a
rolled up curtain that it hung between
them creating a kind of medical tent
around Dr Ham it seemed to stare for
just a moment into the observation
camera outside of itself before whipping
the curtain Shut Dr Ham was discovered 3
hours later crawling around the floor of
049 cell now another mindless Undead
when he was retrieved by security 049
didn't even look up from his notebook Dr
Ham didn't get the incinerator treatment
but he did receive a fatal dose of drugs
a mercy a removal team was sent to 049
cell but it had said there was no need
for special extraction techniques it
would go willingly wherever they wanted
to go it was not it said an enemy of the
people the hypocritic oath forbids me to
hurt a human being it said while walking
to the interrogation Center my only
desire is to offer you my services and
expertise the floors and walls of the
interrogation Center room were painted a
bright white even the table was white
which contrasted with 049 a mass of
black sitting in the middle of the room
during the interrogation it refused to
admit or even accept that it had killed
Dr Ham I cured him I removed the
pestilence from his body it said it was
later asked if it regretted its actions
to which it replied well good sir one
always regrets the loss of a colleague
for any reason but I stand by my actions
the pestilence must be abated before it
is too late every 2 weeks from that
point 049 was given animals the
scientists at the facility observed it
time and again touching the animals
killing them before producing a saw or
scalpel and opening them up organs would
be carefully removed with perfect
Precision it was astounding to even even
trained surgeons just how talented 049
was I require a close relative of yours
said 049 one day to a young Doctor Who
expressed shock that it was asked for
one of the doctor's family members I
mean a great a said 049 not your dear
Aunt there were several instances of 049
displaying a crude sense of humor staff
would almost forget that the thing that
they were talking to wasn't human almost
and it was Dr Thomas morstead that had
supplied the great apes orangutang in
fact that had been rescued from the
rainforests of Borneo only to be taken
to 049 South then one day something
changed 049 told Dr morstead that its
work was done that it accomplished what
it had wanted to do and could someone
remove the cured animal from itself I
think you'd find that it's quite the
work of art a Triumph 049 said through
the intercom when the removal team
entered the cell they found the
orangutang or what was left of it it was
lying in the corner of the cell the top
of its skull had been been removed
leaving its brain Exposed on its face
was the expression of relaxation and
from its mouth it issued very soft
squeaks like that of an infant 049 said
tell Dr Mora that its rage mechanism no
longer exists I've removed the amydala
and made some changes to the
hypothalamus and lyic system it is cured
and quite harmless the next day Dr
morstead announced that he wanted to
visit 049 cell himself after which he
heard A Chorus of disapproval from his
colleag
all telling him that 049 was now too
dangerous Dr Ham was sick replied
morstead and 049 has assured us that he
would never take another human life he's
never lied to us and I'm going to take
him at his word it appeared that 049 had
created the perfect specimen so what was
next Dr morstead had to know everyone is
sick 049 told Dr morstead after the two
had talked for a couple of minutes the
great pandemic has started fear not
doctor I have have a cure no longer will
you humans spread your disease I'm
afraid you are wrong replied the doctor
this pandemic you speak of does not
exist we can happily live with our
pathogens we have done so for Millennial
Dr morstead became angry that he
couldn't get through to 049 I'm afraid
you are suffering from paranoia it is
you who need to be cured you have no
idea said 049 standing up what are you
doing shouted morstad you promis you
wouldn't hurt a human again I'm not
hurting you I'm healing you 049 said and
leapt across the room in a Flash placing
a hand on the doctor's head morstead
slumped to the ground they were being
watched in the observation room and this
had gone too far he had to be moved to
the containment cells permanently mobile
task force Epsilon 11 was right on the
scene and burst through the door no
imagination 049 said to himself those
humans have no imagination at all he
began walking towards the task force who
opened fire on the anomaly but the
bullets bounced off its black code and
mask SCP 049 calmly touched each of the
members of the task force one by one
draining the life from them the last one
standing stopped firing and attempted to
run but again 049 leapt across the room
black cap billowing out behind him and
gently touched the man causing him to
drop to the floor 049 stepped over the
bodies of the Fallen team and walked out
of the containment cell the full details
of what happened next are available only
to the 05 Council what are sometimes
called the overseers the redacted report
that is available reads standard secure
humanoid containment cell research
sector 02 site9 subject SCP 049 date of
breach redacted ukl class SCP 049 breach
cell and subsequently gained access to
adjoining rooms and nearby buildings
breach lasted approximately 3 days and 5
hours total casualties redacted with
redacted number of survivors requiring
incineration therapy course of action
Department of science Alchemy division
suggest suggested injecting anti-trans
morphi disinfectant into class D former
prisoners who were transported to site
and allowed them to come into contact
with SCP 049 SCP failed to reanimate
injected prisoners and cure them SCP 049
acknowledged this failure and
surrendered to mobile task force alpha 1
SCP 049 then requested to be contained
present containment under responsibility
of redacted redacted present location of
SCP 049 redacted end of report SCP 682
must be destroyed as soon as possible so
Begins the SCP Foundation file on the
dreaded SCP 682 a highly intelligent
reptilian monster that has despite the
foundation's best efforts proved
impossible to kill it may not be the
most dangerous SCP out there considering
that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities but it's one of the
most iconic and you've probably heard
tales of the monster that death forgot
and you know exactly why everyone is so
afraid of the so-called called hard
tokill reptile it's been subjected to
some of the most deadly weapons and
traps the foundation could devise and
survived attacks from some of its
deadliest fellow scps but before we tell
you about the foundations many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard- tokill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about SCP 682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead unlike
some other creatures like SCP 09 6 and
SCP 173 which are murderous but exhibit
no real higher processing skills SCP 682
possesses cunning Advanced reasoning and
even human level logical intelligence
SCP 682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage state where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
Beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching it it
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset and
the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli 682 is a reactive being capable
of not only surviving and regenerating
from all attacks but often incorporating
those attacks into its own wide Arsenal
in other words if you're hoping to kill
this thing you better kill it on the
first hit cuz if you don't you better
believe it's going to hit you back a 100
times harder this brings us to the main
event some of the SCP foundation's most
ambitious and frightening attempts to
terminate SCP 682 or even understand how
it could theoretically be terminated
there were quite literally too many
unsuccessful attempts for us to list
them all here so think of this as a
highlight reel of the foundation's most
prominent failures 682 was first cross
tested with SCP 017 a humanoid Shadow
entity shown to be able able to consume
matter with its shadows and leave no
traces behind test on tissue samples
from 682 showed that SCP 017 was able to
consume said tissues with no adverse
effects however when SCP 017 was placed
into the containment chamber with the
actual creature 682 let out a horrific
Roar that was so loud it damaged nearby
audio equipment SCP 017 fled to the
corner of the room and 682 in its rage
State attempted to breach containment
agents managed to suppress and remove
the creature but no meaningful damage
was logged attempt failed SCP 173 the
killer statue was later brought in
hoping that its thus far impeccable
track record for killing what holds
strong the second that 173 was
introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over 6
hours as 682 stared at 173 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682 eyes with high
caliber sniper rifles breaking the line
of sight and causing 173 to attack those
682 sustained damage to several parts of
its body while its eyes regenerated the
creature was not killed it then
regenerated a number of eyes all over
its body covered in a clear armored
carrase that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
Perpetual eye contact 173 was eventually
removed from the containment unit and
the mission was aborted attempt failed
in their desperation the SCP Foundation
restored to bringing in another
dangerous and seemingly unkillable
monster to take on 682 scp096 also known
as the shy guy as astute SCP fans will
already know this being kills anything
that sees its face with no known
exceptions and when it enters it its
attack mode it's thought to be quite
literally
Unstoppable or at least it was while
scp096 was able to destroy 85% of 682s
original body mass during their 27-hour
battle it was left mentally broken
wounded and huddled in the corner to
this day if ever confronted with SCP 682
the shy guy reacts in pure Terror
turning away and clawing at its own face
attempt failed during a deadly
Containment Breach SCP 682 also went
head-to-head organically with another
iconic SCP Hall of Famer SCP 106 also
known as the old man the old man and a
shape-shifting psionic anomaly known as
SCP 953 broke into 682s containment cell
the old man pulled both of his fellow
anomalous combatants into his pocket
Dimension to continue the battle on his
terms however despite losing 67% of his
body mass during the ensuing pocket
Dimension show down 682 still prevailed
with the old man eventually fleeing back
to his cell and 953 being collected and
taken away by agents once again SCP 682
continued to hold the title but it
wasn't just cross testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the SCP
foundation's quest to kill 682 LED them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success due to SCP 682s highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the outset for example launching a
powerful thermonuclear missile at the
creature was soundly rejected by 05
command on the premise that if the
creature wasn't destroyed and evolved to
the point where it could shrug off nukes
Humanity would be pretty much done for
other ideas were abandoned just for
being too ridiculous such as one
researcher suggestion to fly the
creature through the air and drop it
from a considerable height hoping to
kill it with a high altitude impact I'm
not sure we even need to tell you why
that's a terrible idea but during the
experiments on SCP 68 2 the studies
range from honest to incompetent to
straight up
evil one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for a
sadistic Behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct after all the foundation is
meant to be cold not cruel it was SCP
682 that had the Monopoly on cruelty the
medic kill agents were a resounding
failure they attempted to dismember 682
with a powerful laser only to have the
creature develop reflective services
that displac the beam and cause
catastrophic damage to the area around
it they attempted to kill the creature
by sucking all the air out of its
containment facility and create a vacuum
but it expelled a dangerous gaseous
compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again
introduced into the room the foundation
used High Precision Blades to slice SCP
682 into approximately 12,000 pieces
then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12,000 pieces
reformed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know in fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded Itself by developing a second
carace composed of solid helium when
Personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carace into deadly
shards that fired around the room and
shredded all Foundation Personnel in
attendance
it had set a trap and that trap had been
wildly successful the creature's ability
to adapt to seemingly any offense is
unparalleled to the point where
Foundation staff have no idea how to
classify this creature whether it's
organic inorganic or even alive at all
based on any definitions we could
understand at every turn the creature
just raised more questions what is it is
it possible to destroyed At All by any
means who was even trying to kill who
here because it certainly seemed like SC
PP 682 had a masterful KD ratio by now
more extreme Feats of cross testing
continued in the foundation's growing
desperation to eliminate this monster
SCP 162 which is a hypnotic ball of
sharp objects Hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682s
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs however 682 was still able
to breach containment kill 11 people and
badly wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the Beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
Guardian one of the proposals for SCP
001 the guardian had a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of
destroying its Targets on an atomic
level naturally SCP 682 survived and
regenerated perhaps the most fascinating
cross test of all was between 682 and
SCP
053 who manifests as a kind innocent
little girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal
tendencies in all who come into contact
with her for more than 10 minutes the
people with these Tendencies would then
attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researchers
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage State attacks
053 and died for good and the realistic
outcome in which 682 attacked 053
possibly experiencing some minor injury
or nothing at all and 053 had to be
removed from the containment cell but
that didn't happen what did occur was
considerably more shocking than any kind
of violence when 053 entered 682s
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying Immortal Mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out 053 even
appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a single
act in defiance of everything they
thought they knew when Foundation
Personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards 053 also wept
sad at being separated from her new
friend to this day despite further
testing the foundation has no idea how
or why this happened like many details
surrounding SCP 682 it shrouded in
deeply frustrating
mystery and so the tale of SCP 682
continues in spite of the foundation's
best efforts the monster continues to
breach containment and Slaughter with
some regularity taking out its seemingly
Limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath nobody knows where exactly the
creature is from what its true nature is
or why its ability to adapt and
regenerate far exceeds any known
organism on this planet perhaps one day
through enough research and cross
testing we can someday answer these
questions with scientific Precision but
until then we only have one answer
hatred Never Dies working at the SCP
Foundation might just be the most
exciting job a person can ask for and by
exciting we mean that if you work as an
SCP field operative researcher or mobile
Task Force member you're much more
likely to die a horrific death on the
job than say a plumber but at least you
get the honor of proudly saying that
you're the first line of defense between
the normal world and the terrifying
domain of the anomalous well unless
you're one of the it guys then your work
life is likely as tedious and uneventful
as the computer tech guy working on The
Geek Squad but nothing is ever normal
when it comes to the SCP Foundation
where even the person whose job is
helping other staff me members reset
their email passwords may run into the
supernatural welcome to the strange and
frightening world of pattern screamers
and specifically SCP
0000 SCP 0000 was first discovered
completely on accident by technical
researcher David Rosen a man
intrinsically connected to the pattern
screamers lurking on the SCP Foundation
computer database technical researcher
Rosen is actually somewhat of a
celebrity around the foundation staff
due to the fact that he's so perfectly
mediocre at what he does his job as the
glorified it guy at the SCP Foundation
was previously held by the more
qualified researcher Patrick Gart but
Rosen was called in to replace him after
Gart mysteriously disappeared while on
the job since 2012 Rosen has been site
19's user level tech support wizard but
the best thing that can really be said
about his job competency is that he's
got a 100% attendance record he seems to
live out of his office which is
described as the filthiest at the whole
Foundation every inch of the floor is
covered in Old broken computer parts and
the air is stale with dust and the twin
odors of sweat and lithium grease it's a
place so inhospitable that the
foundation has seriously considered
bottling the stench as a kind of
chemical deterrent while technical
director Rosen isn't good at his job per
se he isn't technically bad enough at it
to justify the time and resources it
would take to replace him but the worst
part about Rosen isn't his performance
it's his truly rotten attitude he's
universally described by his colleagues
as being rude grumpy and combative with
patience that's far too short for
someone working in tech support and
while Rosen does have a real fear that
the ghost of researcher Gart is stalking
him he was about to have his first
actual brush with a supernatural it all
started when he began receiving
automated repair tickets for SC CP
0000 a file that had no reason to exist
as any longtime follower of the SCP
Foundation will know the universal
designation for the first cluster of
scps to be discovered is SCP 001 there
is no SCP
0000 it simply doesn't exist and when
Rosen first found the file lurking on
the database he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense the object class
was recorded as null the special
containment procedures read error field
containment procedures does not exist
and the mess of a description simply
read internal system error field
undefined please contact system
administrator over and over again
becoming more mangled and nonsensical
each time technical director Rosen who
could never resist an opportunity to
complain decided to leave an angry
administrator's note on the useless file
he claimed that this pile of junk data
was sending out pointless repair tickets
because of its broken syntax clogging up
the system and preventing him from doing
actual work on meaningful files he
assumed that this was all down to the
database not knowing how to react to
having files logged with insufficient
information and he suppressed all future
repair tickets from SCP 0000 before
declaring the matter over and done with
what the pigheaded technical director
didn't realize was that he was
suppressing a call for help from an
entity trapped in the white space below
the article itself it was a being born
into a pure white world of absolute
nothingness an entity with no name and
no place but it was somehow capable of
thought its panicked inner monologue is
readable in the hidden text which takes
the form of a rambling stream of
Consciousness the being first described
coming to life in this empty world with
no memories of where it was or even how
it got there it spent what could have
been years exploring the empty Wasteland
occasionally it would see horrific
monsters pop up arounded but only for a
split second The Entity continued to
wander and little by little the
existential dread mounted as it realized
that it may truly be stuck here in
Oblivion Forever The Entity only had one
word to go on a word repeated by some of
the monsters it encountered Foundation
The Entity had no idea what this
Foundation even was but it grew to hate
and fear it was this Foundation the one
that trapped it here the entity at all
the Time in the World to speculate on it
eventually The Entity found its voice
like any sentient creature in trouble it
began to call for help eventually
screaming just hoping someone would
notice it these pleas likely translated
into the frequent it repair tickets a
coded SOS an attempt to show that
everything was not as it appeared on the
SCP 0000 file perhaps The Entity may
have found help if researcher Gart was
still working at the foundation but
instead its cries fell on the ignorant
ears of technical director Rosen it may
as well have been speaking to a brick
wall Rosen who had all the investigative
Zeal of Paul Blart mop made sure that
these cries would never lead to the
entity's freedom when he suppressed the
repair tickets he had trapped the entity
in a private blank hell forever hating a
life it didn't choose and could never
escape a Relentless existential
nightmare this is the gist of your Aver
brid pattern screamer pattern screamers
are a perfect example of literally
making something out of nothing they are
often a kind of floating Consciousness
created from nothing Trapped In Pockets
of nothingness between the fabric of
reality driven mad by the Purgatory like
nature of their existence they're less
living entities and more conceptual
constructs pure ideas that just happen
to be self-aware of their own existence
in their private hellish voids the SCP
0000 file a file for for an anomaly that
doesn't exist and thus had no reason to
exist is a perfect breeding ground for a
pattern screamer but sadly for the
pattern screamer in question technical
director Rosen had no idea this isn't
the only time that Rosen had run into a
pattern screamer without even knowing
either and just like the first case he
was with no help whatsoever this one
began with
scps an otherwise empty file containing
only this image director Winters a
foundation administrator wondered why
this file even existed enter technical
director Rosen filled with equal parts
sarcasm and insubordination he gave a
condescending reply to director Winters
saying that the file was there to test
the filing system and the image was
likely just a placeholder Winters never
should have been on the page anyway
according to Rosen director Winters was
annoyed at rosen's typically rude tone
and asked him to make the purpose of the
article clearer in the article itself in
response Rosen did as he was told
filling the article in the most
sarcastic manner possible the whole
thing was essentially a middle finger to
director Winters for having the audacity
to even ask Rosen signed off with there
finished I certainly hope I have been
clear enough to anyone who may have
accidentally access this page through
what I am sure is no fault of their own
so we won't have any more incredibly
competent directors bugging the tech
team about this page and once again
technical research arose in was too busy
being a rude unpleasant jerk to notice
he was practically staring another
pattern screamer in the face this
pattern screamer or rather Hive of
pattern screamers were trapped even
deeper than the one in SCP 0000 this one
was hidden in the very source code of
scps where a chorus of enraged voices
screamed the following pretend monster
just for a minute pretend you were the
size of an amoeba dwarfed by even the
smallest of bugs pretend you didn't hold
the world in a glass cage pretend you
were the one being held by something
greater than yourself would you still be
laughing at your triumphs would you
still feel pride in what you were even
as pitifully small as you would be of
course you would because you are
arrogant and stupid if you haven't
guessed yet we hate you this pattern
screamer is clearly more aware of its
pitiful station in existence than the 00
Z pattern screamer and as a result it's
not so much depressed as it is furious
though at this point you've probably
figured out that even the entities who
have the most casual brushes with
technical researcher Rosen end up
getting infuriated but while you may
have gotten the impression that all
pattern screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity
there's at least one pattern screamer
that's actually incredibly dangerous
this is SCP 3930 the ultimate pattern
screamer in terms of both size and
effect it's an anomaly so strange it
defies typical containment
classification and it Bears a level five
security lock meaning only those on the
level of the legendary 05 Council are
cleared to even know about it its
greatest containment procedure is the
preservation of the very idea that SCP
3930 does not exists because the
alternative has terrifying implications
for all involved scp3 930 is a 1 km area
in Russia that is filled with
non-existence to even call it a white
void would be inaccurate because it
implies the existence of the color white
and the existence of the concept of a
void nothing exists with an SCP 3930 and
anyone who directly observes 3930 runs
the risk of actively increasing its
power that's why special containment
procedures dictate that anyone who
observes 3930 must be forced to walk
into it afterwards which results in them
ceasing to exist they're destroyed on
the deepest level that anything can be
destroyed the very idea of them ceases
to be another reason that SCP 3930 is so
special is that because it's the largest
area of nothing in existence interacting
directly with our reality it's the only
place that a huge number of pattern
screamers can be directly observed by
humans they're described as being like
sentient hallucinations one researcher
suggests that these pattern screamers
are created by the way the psyche
shatters when brought into contact with
raw true nothingness the nothingness
acts like a hateful mirror to our worst
thoughts reflecting them back at us in
the forms of restless screamers
regardless of what they actually are one
thing is for sure coming into direct
contact with one of these screamers is a
harrowing experience in the end it just
goes to show that pattern screamers are
a complex entity they can range from
microscopic to massive from pitiful to
downright terrifying and the sad result
is that in either case nothing can
really be done to stop them it's just as
impossible to stop the nothingness
existing in SCP 3930 as it is to save
the entity trapped in the white spaces
of SCP
0000 maybe the best option is to
actually be more like technical director
Rosen keep your head down Focus instead
on your own Petty worries and bask in
the warm Bliss that can only come with
having no idea what you're dealing with
the one downside is that this may make
you a pretty lousy it guy flying in a
plane nowadays is about as safe as
catching a ride on a bus or commuting on
the subway of course that doesn't stop
people being afraid of fly to some the
prospect of Long Haul flights or feeling
the shudder of turbulence are reasons to
avoid planes alt together and then every
year there are stories of down flights
or those that go missing all adding fuel
to that aviophobia fire take for example
the infamous Bermuda Triangle that
well-known region of the western part of
the North Atlantic Ocean what does that
have to do with a fear of flying well
famously a high number of aircraft are
believed to have mysteriously vanished
while flying over the Bermuda Triangle
their wreckage and passengers rarely
ever recovered stories like that are
enough to make anyone think twice about
setting foot in a plane again and then
there's SCP
787 as you may have already guessed SCP
787 is a plane specifically it is a
Boeing
747-200 with a wingspan of nearly 200 ft
and capable of seating over 800
passengers the 7472 200 is a part of the
famous Boeing 747 family of aircraft
these are quad engine commercial
airliners designed to be the safest ever
built the particular Boeing
74700 that has since become known by the
foundation as SCP 787 is slightly
different from one that might take you
from your nearest airport to your long-
awaited vacation though for one SCP 787
has no known date of manufacturer and no
call sign both which a standard Boeing
aircraft would be expected to have
Additionally the plane's entire exterior
has been repainted strangely even the
windows have been painted over and the
paint was still wet when SCP 787 was
first discovered covered as for the
inner workings all of SCP 787's
mechanical components including its
turbines engines and landing gear are in
perfect working order with no signs of
any damage in fact the SCP foundation's
researchers aren't even sure that SCP
787 has actually flown since its
construction the plane's Machinery looks
so pristine that they might be brand new
with no detectable signs of any previous
use however inside the main body of the
plane it seems to be a different story
anything not mechanical like the carpets
and seats have decayed over time perhaps
strangest of all is the cockpit both the
pilots and co-pilot's chairs have been
replaced with two masses of computer
components arranged to take the shape of
two chairs so what you might be thinking
after all SCP 787 is for all intents and
purposes just an ordinary plane not
enough to put you off flying right
nothing more than a Boeing with a few
little things off about it like some
missing seats and decaying upholstery
well there's that and then there's the
over 500 dead bodies on board in June
1987 this flight of the Dead was
discovered several kilometers outside of
the city of Bremerton in Washington
state the SCP Foundation moved in
securing the plane and swiftly getting
it into containment now kept within a
foundation hanger the interior of SCP
787 is monitored for 24 hours a day
surveillance cameras and microphones are
located within the cockpit passenger
areas and even the plane's baggage hold
with recorded footage and sound relay
back to the foundation the idea of a
plane filled with cavers is certainly
unnerving and more than a little creepy
but why the need for all the
surveillance after all the bodies on
board are all dead right surely they're
not going anywhere well let's talk about
those bodies how would you expect
someone to die when they are aboard a
plane maybe they'd be thrown around
during a crash landing or perhaps a
sudden depressurization might cause the
passengers to suffocate due to lack of
oxygen under normal circumstances you
might be right but SCP 787 is no
ordinary plane and the passengers on
board were not killed in ways you might
expect from any ordinary aircraft
accident referred to by research staff
as SCP 787a specimens the cavers aboard
this particular Boeing
747-200 all have dramatically different
causes of death some of the specimens
show signs of strangulation others seem
to have starved or drowned other bodies
on board have injuries like gunshot or
stab wounds while further corpses look
to have died as a result of blunt force
trauma a few have even been ex
sanguinated that is completely drained
of all of their blood one commonality
among all the specimens on board SCP 787
is that some form of Mutilation has
occurred 23 passengers had their tongues
removed a further 73 were scalped 230
had cerlic letters carved into their
left hands and almost 500 of the
passengers had their fingertips removed
let's recap what we have so far first
there's the Boeing 74700 found randomly
sitting in a field second it's filled
with over 500 mutilated bodies and third
each one appears to have died from a
cause you wouldn't typically expect from
an airline accident seems strange enough
but of course then there's the
apparitions and Noise es that manifest
inside SCP 787 which is why the
foundation keeps the plane under round
the-clock surveillance so they can
monitor any anomalous activity taking
place aboard this flight of the Dead any
attempts by Foundation Personnel to
enter the plane during an anomalous
occurrence have led to individuals being
physically ejected from SCP 787 causing
severe organ damage and internal
bleeding for up to 72 hours the
anomalies that occur inside SCP 787
range from the presence of loud noises
with no obvious source to the
manifestation of strange human-shaped
entities within the plane the first
anomalous occurrence recorded with an
SCP 787 was in 1988 when the sound of a
loud pounding Was Heard against the
doors and windows of the plan's left
side 2 years later a male voice could be
heard from the onboard bathroom
repeating a singular phrase over and
over philosophers always run from the
advanced thickening treatment in 1993
the planes inflated Entertainment System
seemed to be activated by itself the
overhead screen showed a bizarre choice
of inflight movie colorless pictures of
a deceased man accompanied by a female
voice reading a Gynecology book in check
the same year the longest lasting of the
SCP 787 anomalies took place this time
the plane's fasten seat Bel sign spent
almost 4 hours flickering while the
first 15 seconds of Jefferson airplane's
White Rabbit played on a loop over the
onboard speakers it wasn't until 1997
that the first of the humanoid entities
appeared aboard SCP 787 this figure was
indistinct lacking any discernable
detail little more than just a human
shape standing in the aisles observed by
the foundation's surveillance equipment
the figure was seen removing an
emergency oxygen supply and mask from
seat
h43 it stood perfectly still wearing the
passenger's breathing mask for over 2
minutes before removing the mask and
disappearing from the view of the camera
Camas placed on board the figure did not
appear anywhere else inside the plane
another figure appeared 4 years later in
2001 sitting in the massive computer
parts that made up the co-pilot's chair
this figure much like its predecessor
was indistinct in its features for
almost 4 minutes it sat in the cockpit
of the Boeing
747-200 just whimpering softly then it
lurched forward vomiting all over the
console in front of it before quickly
disappearing like the first figure SCP
Personnel collected a sample of the
vomit The Entity Left Behind after
performing an analysis of the sample
research staff found traces of nitrous
oxide thorium bird droppings and three
human fingernails at present the origin
of these humanoid figures is still
unknown could these entities be the
souls of the Dead passengers trying to
offer insight into what happened aboard
this flight or perhaps these indistinct
human-shaped creatures are the ones
responsible for the deaths of SCP 787's
passengers the next anomaly with an SCP
787 occurred in 2005 when a female voice
was recorded speaking through the
onboard speaker system the voice said
for your comfort and enjoyment today
pancakes will now be served please do
not leave your seat pancakes will now be
served please do not leave your seat do
not leave your seat leave your seat
please pancakes will now be served yay
pancakes exactly what the re relevance
of Pancakes are to a Plane full of
bodies is still under investigation by
the SCP Foundation next in 2007 the
Boeing's overhead emergency air masks
fell from the ceiling only to be
snatched back upwards they continued
deploying and retracting for 14 minutes
while the plane was simultaneously
filled with the noise of Screams finally
the only other notable anomaly took
place a year later when the onboard
temperature with an SCP 787 dropped
33° from 20 to -3 C in a matter of
seconds by the late 2000s the
foundation's researchers was having
little luck understanding the nature of
SCP 787's anomalies instead they turned
their attention to identifying the
bodies of the deceased passengers on
board through the use of advanced
forensics and population databases these
researchers attempted to determine where
exactly these bodies had come from
researchers still haven't determined if
they all died on the plane or if someone
had exhumed them from great AV before
placing them aboard for some unknown
reason in fact the answer was neither
and Foundation researchers discovered
something that no one had expected one
of the passengers was still alive to
clarify the body aboard SCP 787 was
definitely still deceased but
researchers identified the caver as a
retired optometrist from Atlanta Georgia
who is still very much alive Foundation
agents found the man was simultaneously
alive and well in his Atlanta home but
also dead on on board the Boeing
747-200 the subject was interviewed by
agents and had no prior knowledge of any
incident taking place in June 1987 when
SCP 787 was first discovered even more
interestingly he claimed that he never
even set foot aboard an airplane which
his wife and son both confirmed to be
true so what does this mean how could
the same man have been alive in Georgia
and dead aboard SCP 787 perhaps the
answer can be found in a surprising
place place the plan's toilet or to be
more specific the place where the things
flushed in the toilet go to examinations
of the airplane's waste storage tank
have revealed something very surprising
there was one more SCP 787a specimen
that had been overlooked it is unknown
just how he got in there but researchers
discovered the body of an Indian man who
looked to be in his 30s the man who is
wearing a three-piece suit was found to
be carrying a number of puzzling items
including a surgical mask and gloves
an unloaded beta dt10 shotgun several
cinnamon flavored mints a switchblade
knife an amulet that appears to depict
the Eye of Horus and a ticket stub for
the Return of the Jedi with the number
92 written on the back all of these
objects seem to be completely random and
the foundation has been unable to make
sense of what they were doing on the man
or why his body does not seem to show
the same state of decay as the rest of
those found on board there was one item
that may hold some an though for some
reason this man also possessed a copy of
SCP 787's flight log the log consisted
of a series of coordinates which were
repeated
5,478 times the coordinates point to a
seemingly random spot in the Pacific
Ocean several hundred miles away from
the infamous pitan Islands the island
that the famous mutineers of the HMS
Bounty settled after taking over the
ship and leaving the captain a drift on
the ocean is this location the secret to
SCP 787 while none of this is confirmed
nor denied by anyone at the SCP
Foundation One Theory surrounding the
area is that the location is another
Bermuda Triangle like location one that
contains some sort of temporal anomaly
that unwitting planes fly through only
to find themselves displaced in time of
course the problem with this theory is
that the man from Atlanta said he'd
never been aboard a plane before or at
least not yet it is entirely possible
that SCP 787 is a plane that made a
flight at some point in the not too
distant future only to arrive back in
June 1987 by passing through a temporal
breach in the area near the pitan
islands sure it might not explain what
happened to everyone on board but it
could at least explain how SCP 787
arrived where and when it did every
plane is fitted with a device that
records flight data in the event of a
crash or other accident known to most as
the plan's black box and researchers
were able to uncover SCP 787s inside a
compartment under under one of the
plane's seats the recorder was found
within a compartment filled with toxic
asbest and dried human blood they hope
that perhaps it would contain some
answers as to what exactly SCP 787 had
come from and what had happened to its
passengers sadly not the flight data
recorder contained no information
besides one simple phrase to be sorry
while an inexplicable mystery SCP 787 is
at least classified as a safe Anomaly by
the foundation seeing as it poses no
realistic threat or shows signs of
trying to break out of containment the
aircraft has only ever caused harm to
anyone trying to enter during one of its
sporadic anomalous events but apart from
that it sits Gathering dust in a hanger
just waiting for someone to crack its
secrets and who knows maybe one day
you'll be sitting on a plane that's
taking you to your South Pacific
vacation and the retired optometrist
sitting next to you will remark that
you're passing over the pitan islands
and you'll discover for yourself exactly
what happened to SCP 787 the first thing
that tips the foundation off to SCP 87's
presence were the reports of numerous
unexplained disappearances on campus
there were plenty of rumors about what
might be behind them but field agents
suspected that the true source of the
vanishing would be something Beyond
civilian imagination all anyone knew for
sure was that everyone who had gone
missing was last seen in a certain
Administrative Building on the
University grounds and that the
disappearance
only seemed to happen when the elevator
was out the campus was soon flooded with
Foundation agents creating a barrier
around the administrative building and
the presumed habitat of SCP 087 nobody
else could get in and hopefully whatever
was inside couldn't get out one of the
foundation's lead scientists was flown
in to consult on the investigation what
could have been behind those students
disappearing the doctor's preliminary
interviews with University staff who
worked in the building yielded some
interesting details strange noises like
banging and even a faint shrill crying
would be heard from a door that led to a
no longer used stairway in hallway 3B
staff in the building had no reason to
ever take these stairs especially
considering how many of them reported a
strange sense of unease when just
standing outside the door the only
reason someone might take those stairs
is due to elevator
malfunctions in that instant the doctor
had put it all together the staff they
interviewed had their memory wiped with
amnestics special chemicals used by the
foundation with the power to delete
human Memories the foundation only used
them for staff for civilians who had
confirmed contact with an SCP and the
doctor knew that they had a live one on
their hands the staircase there was
something terribly wrong with that
staircase and it was the SCP
foundation's job to find out what before
it made anybody else disappear this is
the story of SCP 087 otherwise known as
the endless staircase in the three Doom
Journeys down into its murky depths the
doctor was more than eager to begin
Research into the staircase and its
frightening anomalous properties after
all you don't claw your way up to being
one of the foundation's key researchers
without being brave and perhaps just a
little bit deranged as was standard once
a perimeter was secured around the
staircase the good doctor requested a
selection of d-class personnel for
testing for those not in the know
d-class is the foundation's polite way
of saying Canon F the doctor was sent
three d-class prisoners for use in his
investigation of SCP
087 the first d-8432 was according to
official documentation on the incident a
43-year-old male of average build and
appearance and unremarkable
psychological background this man once
worked for the foundation in a more
official capacity but he was given the
often deadly demotion to declass due to
a dangerous mistake handling SCP 682
that led to the deaths of several other
agents now it looked like it would be
his turn the doctor explained his
mission to him explore the staircase
gather data help us find out exactly
what we're dealing with here if you come
back alive there may even be a promotion
in it for you and with that promise d432
was given his load out a 75 wat flood
lamp with battery power capable of
lasting 24 hours an audio headset and a
handheld camcorder fitted with a
transmission stream and an audio headset
that would allow him to communicate with
Dr Bryant d-8432 was then pushed through
the door in hallway 3B and out onto the
staircase according to Declassified
Foundation files describing the
staircase SCP 087 is an unlit platform
staircase stairs descend on a 38° angle
for 13 steps before reaching a
semicircular platform of approximately 3
m in diameter descent Direction rotates
1080° at each platform the design of SCP
087 limits subjects to a visual range of
approximately 1.5 flights but in d-8432
mind unlit really didn't seem like the
right word he would have chosen all
consuming Darkness despite carrying a
powerful 75 wat lamp d-8432 was only
capable of partially lighting the
platform he was standing on and the
illumination only stretched down nine of
the 13 steps to the next platform when
d-8432 observed how little help his lamp
was giving him he was instructed to
shine it out of the doorway in to
hallway 3B when he did so the light
seemed to shine far further than it ever
could in SCP
087 already the beginning of the
anomalous activity was obvious
everywhere else darkness is just the
absence of light in SCP 087 Darkness
eats light it was like a tangible black
mass that only a certain amount of light
could survive while the rest just
wouldn't show d-8432 swallowed hard over
a lump in his throat the door to hallway
3B was closed behind
and he was ordered to descend surviving
to see that promotion was feeling
unlikely but it's not like he had a
choice if he tried to escape SCP 087
before he was permitted he'd be shot by
SCP Foundation field agents on the spot
so he followed the high ranking doctor's
orders and began to descend the steps to
the next platform nothing about the
physical makeup of the staircase itself
seemed abnormal the base and walls were
a very plain dull concrete with a metal
handrail the only thing that seemed
unique about it so far was The Strange
Life bending properties that was until
he reached the second platform down and
he heard it a soft echoing cry a child's
cry it his shrieks of Panic or maybe
even pain echoing Up From Below he was
asked why he had stopped and he
explained the crying sound he'd been
hearing it sounded like it was coming
from far down the stairs maybe 200 M
below him he could just make out the
words please help and down here coming
from the darkness but the team outside
the stairwell couldn't hear anything so
they asked him to descend further
another platform down and they could
hear it too the unmistakable cries of a
terrified child please help and down
here d432 was ordered to keep going and
only stop if he noticed changes to the
visual environment or in the sounds he
was hearing d-8432 knowing his life was
on the line had to keep going and
descended another 20 flights of stairs
before stopping to remark that the
sounds of the hadn't gotten any closer
they still sounded just as far away as
when he' first heard them he was told
his observations were noted and
pressured to continue within half an
hour d-8432 had descended a full 50
floors with no sign of a bottom in sight
somehow the volume of the child's crying
had remained consistent throughout as if
it was moving away from d432 at the same
rate he was descending at this point
d-8432 reported that he was feeling
uneasy the doctor said that this was
understandable given the circumstances
he'd been watching what little there was
to see over a live video feed the entire
time and something about the truly
bottomless nature of the staircase and
the ever elusive crying was undeniably
eerie but things were about to really
take a turn for the worst as d-8432
stepped forward towards the next set of
stairs he froze there was something on
the platform below him barely
illuminated by the light of his 75w bolt
it was a face vaguely human in size and
shape but with a few terrifying
differences it had grayish skin and no
mouth nostrils or pupils and yet d432
could feel that this thing was making
eye contact with him he couldn't move
trapped in the thing's piercing gaze in
an instant the face jerked forwards
suddenly only about a foot away from
d432 face eyes staring into its own d432
screamed and ran scaling all 50 flights
in an astonishing 18 minutes before
charging out into hallway 3B there he
collapsed from the exhaustion and the
fear of what he just seen upon reviewing
the footage the strange face was
designated SCP
87-1 fascinating it was time for a
second experiment the doctor just had to
know more the second test subject was
d935 a 28-year-old male with a history
of aggravated assaults against women he
was given the same load out as his
predecessors except this time with an
even more powerful 100 wat bulb it was
also given 100 small LED lights that had
adhesive backs and a battery life of
approximately 3 weeks with which they
intended to permanently illuminate SCP
087 however despite the extra wattage of
his bulb he still couldn't illuminate
beyond the ninth step SCP 087 wouldn't
allow it having no ideas of the horrors
that lurk below him he descended on the
doctor's orders and began fixing the
LEDs to the walls of each platform he
passed the LED always illuminated The
Landing but the light couldn't pass the
first step on either side the flights of
stairs themselves would remain in
Perpetual Darkness after the second
flight d935 noticed the same crying D
8432 had heard and became uneasy just
like before as d935 descended the volume
of the crying didn't seem to increase as
if for every step he descended the
source of the crime descended one two
keeping them at a constant two 200 M
apart still He was ordered to continue
his descent and the placing of LEDs even
as his paranoia grew when he reached the
51st floor he observed damage to the
wall and steps sections appear to have
been smashed to Rubble by an extreme
force as he descended past the broken
step he only felt his fear anxiety and
paranoia grow the doctor made note of
the fact that SCP 087 seemed to cause
instances of anxiety and Terror in its
occupants even before they encountered
SCP
87-1 as d935 reached platform 89 a full
350 M under the initial platform he
stopped dead in his tracks and saw
something staring up at him from the
platform below that same terrible gray
face with those dead white eyes he was
encouraged to stay calm and try to get
better footage of the face but it
charged for him and d935 ran for his
life he ascended the staircase at a
staggering Pace even passing out from
exhaustion and remaining motionless for
14 minutes halfway when d935 finally
gathered the strength to get up he
scrambled back to hallway 3B and fell
into a state of Catatonia he remains
unresponsive to all external stimuli to
this day just staring off into the
distance with a haunted expression
almost like he's still there in the
hallway the doctor wanted to conduct one
more test before he ordered SCP 087 shut
up off from the world forever and it was
the most terrifying of all the final
subject was D
9884 a 23-year-old woman with a history
of depression and use of excessive force
the doctor had hoped that d98 A4 would
travel the deepest yet and so he gave
her the additional supplies of a
backpack containing 3.75 L of water 15
nutrient bars and one thermal blanket as
far as the foundation was concerned she
was in this for the Long Haul but none
of them had any idea quite how right
they were when D 9884 entered SCP 087
all the lights from the previous
Expedition had disappeared still she was
ordered to go deeper she heard the
crying of the mysterious child if it was
even a child at all and again she was
ordered to go deeper at the 496th
Landing even as Dean 9884 seemed to slip
into a state of mortal Terror once again
she was ordered to go even deeper every
moment he was hoping to get get a better
look at the face of SCP
87-1 and when de 9884 finally broke and
fled back upstairs he did the face
appeared but this time it was mere
inches behind her staring directly into
the camera with its blank eyes startling
even this veteran of the supernatural
the face appearing caused D 9884 to
panic and flee but instead of going back
up the stairs to safety she went deeper
down the staircase in an attempt to
escape it deeper and deeper and deeper
until her video feed cut out d98 A4 was
never seen again in the aftermath of the
tests the SCP was classified as uclid it
may have been dangerous but at least it
was easy to contain the door to hallway
3B was replaced with one made out of
reinforced steel with an electro release
lock mechanism it has been disguised to
resemble a janitorial closet consistent
with the rest of the building the lock
won't release unless a classified number
of electrical volts are applied while
the key is turned counterclockwise and
after a few inches of foam insulation
were applied to the inner side of the
door staff at the building never again
reported hearing strange noises as for
the fates of those lost within the
endless turning flights and platforms of
SCP 087 we may never know but one can
only assume it isn't Pleasant over 50
men and women clad in red robes kneel
before an Unholy altar they chant and
mutter indecipherable words words of of
Cruelty and Madness of obsession and
sacrilege not long ago these were
regular people computer technicians
teachers plumbers construction workers
accountants this was before they fell
under the ungodly influence of a new
ruler the center of this makeshift place
of worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles it head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face while he's known to
the cultist as the tentacled god the
Beast they worship is known to the SCP
Foundation as SCP
2662 and he sits in the belly of one of
their expansive containment facilities
locked away from the world but not for
long if his devoted followers have
anything to say about it this is their
God all powerful and unchanging and when
it comes to springing him from
containment no tactic is too vile or
underhanded to get the job done their
mortal leader and high priest a man in a
purple robe calling himself brother
Marsh walks among their crouched forms
he whispers instructions for the great
day of Liberation that's soon to come
providing everyone plays their part it's
a plan months in the making and one that
if it goes off without a hitch could
free their monstrous God into the world
World they would strike at the very
heart of their enemy the SCP Foundation
when they least expect it and nothing
shall stand in their way how could they
lose when they have a God on their side
but why did all these normal people
become violent zealots for a squidface
deity it all began with a dream to those
who experienced these dreams they felt
more like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God holding Dominion overall
at first it just seemed like a strange
nightmare the ones who experienced it
woke up shaken and Afraid hoping to
shake the images from their mind but
they couldn't every night the nightmare
would return they'd see the images the
Red Sky the dead and Enslaved the
tentacled God and after a while it would
come come to them even when they weren't
asleep eventually happening whenever
they closed their eyes little by little
this scene stopped looking so hideous
and started to look glorious they felt
his presence in their minds slowly
pushing them towards their inevitable
future they started to realize that they
wanted him to rule over the universe and
to experience the honor of serving him
many of them abandoned their homes and
families leaving their friends and loved
ones left to worry that they'd Gone
Insane In Their Eyes they were safer
than they'd ever been they finally had
purpose they were working in service of
something far greater than themselves
the influence of the tentacled god drew
them closer to one another they would
meet in secret exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent to
them in their dreams they worship
together building altars and Idols to
congregate around they performed dark
blood rituals in involving human and
animal sacrifice it was when brother
Marsh the anointed one arrived to guide
them towards their true mission that
things kicked into high gear just 3
months prior brother Marsh had been an
office drone working in data entry for a
large insurance company before the
tentacled god invaded His Thoughts with
a simple message free me and the new
world I create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
completely to the cause quitting his job
and maxing out his credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the SCP Foundation and releasing his
inhuman ruler from its imprisonment that
was the single goal he United the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
God and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary Intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on Earth even the strongest
institution is made of people and people
are weak unlike the almighty tentacled
God people could be broken the people in
question were Kelly Thompson cydney
levit Jordan broch Dr Juan gutieres and
Jillian lson Dr Juan Gutierrez was a
researcher with level three clearance on
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained Sydney levit and Jordan
broch were both security officers
charged with verifying Personnel
clearance on site
Kelly Thompson was a member of site
Administration with research
authorization powers and Jillian Larson
was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr Gutierrez these
five were the key to getting access to
SCP
2662 and bringing their plan to fruition
normally Personnel dossier on people
working for the foundation were highly
confidential but the devotees of the
tentacled God had their ways they had a
number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in
and pulling some basic information off
of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turn to some good
oldfashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results of course while the Colts
grip on sanity may have been a little
tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against SCP 2662 was being held in a
humanoid containment cell and guarded by
on-site Task Force Town 9 better known
as the belligerent bodyguards these
aren't lazy dut chopping Mall Cops these
are a heavily trained heavily armed
fighting force though the cultist had
one thing that these Foundation soldiers
didn't the element of surprise for
everything to go off perfectly brother
Marsh's plans would have to be executed
within a single day and they were
already on the clock T 9 had been
charged with tracking down any new SCP
2662 Colts and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they need
to strike quickly and with overwhelming
Force the SCP 2662 worshippers were able
to secure the addresses of the five key
Foundation personnel and station members
outside each of them
including one who could realistically
imitate each they waited for night to
fall and broke into each of their homes
as they slapped What followed was a
sequence of Ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their God Dr Gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept Sydney levit and
Jordan broch were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening Thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire Jillian Larson had
scene that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular
humans so far brother Marsh's plan had
gone perfectly with all five key
personnel murdered within a 2-minute
period next the selected doppelgangers
stole clothes from their victim's
closets and were handed the correct
Forge documentation the next morning
each replacement began their Journeys to
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained while the rest of the
cult armed themselves in preparation for
their own part in the plan nobody at the
foundation seemed to notice anything a
miss when the five arrived on site when
you work for the SCP Foundation more
mental energy is devoted to following
the rules that keep you alive than two
memorizing the faces of all your
co-workers and each one SLI neatly into
position disappearing into the
familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site headon
in the ensuing chaos the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site
could take advantage of the distraction
and break into the containment chamber
it was perfect they launched their
attack from the outside and from within
when brother Marsh declared that the
time was right the assault began a
legion of gun wielding culas seemed to
Spring out of nowhere and started
shooting up the warehouse that was a
front for the containment site the site
quickly mobilized guards and task force
members to take on the sudden threat and
just as brother Marsh had anticipated
the site director called on the majority
of town 9 to help repel the violent
cultist from their perimeter Town N9
obeyed leaving three task force members
behind a guard SCP 2662 containment
chamber they expected to be guarding the
cell from rampaging religious zealots
seeking an audience with their God what
they didn't expect was a group of five
Foundation employees walking right up to
them and opening fire killing two Tow n
members and taking the third as hostage
while the war was being waged outside
the infiltrators had found the tentacle
Gods containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid Ward their hostage insisted
that using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood SCP
2662 twice as tall as regular man with
10 huge tentacles emerging from its back
in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen still
Gods work in mysterious ways so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting
they pulled out a sacrificial dagger and
began sacrificing their captured Town n
member it was at this point that SCP
2662 turned and saw what they were doing
with a look of pure horror he rose up
from his computer his headphones getting
caught as he did so he told them to go
away that he didn't want them here and
that the murdering people in his bedroom
like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultist became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor in
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
Lov crafty and God to just leave him
alone so he could play his video games
this was seriously not cool the cultists
were baffled they told the tentacled god
that they were there to free him he
replied that he didn't need saving that
crazy stalkers like them were why he
turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662 cell this was a common
occurrence
Unfortunately they had to deal with an
attempted cult Invasion every few months
because SCP 2662 is main anomalous
ability is inspiring violent Cults who
relentlessly track down and worship it
with Arcane and bloodthirsty rituals the
problem is 2662 doesn't do this
consciously and definitely doesn't like
the result
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Colts who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Colts who'd broken into 2662
containment cell the remaining Town n
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again SCP 2662 cell was
repaired and the foundation returned to
its task of seeking out wouldbe cult
emancipator because for the SCP
Foundation it's not always about the
anomaly that's being kept in containment
but what's being kept out ever since she
was in high school Faith had dreamed of
moving out and finally getting a place
of her own it wasn't that she didn't
love her parents she did but they were
always around always coming into her
room without knocking telling her when
to go to bed when to wake up not to eat
dinner in front of the TV in college she
had some welcome Independence but she
had to live with roommates again they
were perfectly nice people some of them
she even considered good friends but she
hated having to share her space having
to come home from a long day of classes
and see someone else's dishes piled up
in the sink to have someone else's music
keeping her awake at night to delay her
morning shower because someone else had
gotten there first so she was thrilled
when a few years after graduating she
got a new job at a marketing company
that would finally let her afford a
place by herself at last she could have
some peace some quiet and most
importantly some privacy Faith spent all
day moving furniture and unpacking boxes
turning the little apartment into a real
home it wasn't much just a main room she
used as a bedroom and living room a
bathroom and a basic little kitchen but
it was all hers and all of the little
personal touches she'd put together
really made it feel like the place was
meant for her there was the orange couch
she'd picked up at a vintage store
downtown the coffee table she'd gotten
for free from her last roommate brain
pictures of her family and friends a bed
with Linens in her favorite color light
blue and lots and lots of potted plants
over time she would find even more
things more little personal touches to
liven up the space face now how to
celebrate her new home her gas wasn't on
yet so she couldn't cook anything but
that was the perfect excuse to order in
30 minutes or less later she was kicking
back on her couch with a large cheese
pizza watching a scarying movie on her
TV no one would ask to switch it over to
the bachelor no one would take the last
slice while she was in the bathroom it
was perfect finally A Little Piece of
Heaven an introverts Paradise nice as
she finished her first meal in the new
place she felt her eyes beginning to
grow heavy the day of strenuous
unpacking catching up with her body just
as she was thinking about calling it a
night a pale-faced monster appeared out
of nowhere on screen terrifying the
movie's main character and making Faith
jump spilling her soda all over the
coffee table damn it she groaned already
she'd made a mess but hey she tried to
look on the bright side it was yet
another first to break in the apartment
she grabbed a kitchen towel to mop up
the soda and when she returned to the
main room she froze there was something
in the window standing out against the
darkness outside at first she thought it
was a reflection a trick of the light
but as she slowly approached the window
eyes wide and hands trembling she got a
better look there was a face a little
difficult to make out as if it were
peering Out of the Shadows but
unmistakable nonetheless it was p veale
human vaguely resembling a strange man
with dark circles under his eyes and he
was looking right at her she didn't
scream she was too terrified to make a
sound she stared at the face for a long
moment waiting for it to do something
anything after several moments of the
tensest staring contest of her life she
blinked the face didn't budge ye you
need to leave she finally spoke
surprising herself as she did if you
don't get out of here I'm calling the
cops again again the face stood nothing
do you hear me her voice climbed in
Pitch her heart pounding against the
inside of her chest who was he what did
he want she became vaguely aware of the
fact that she couldn't see the rest of
the man's body just his face looking at
her with a neutral expression a look of
vague curiosity like someone watching a
caged animal at the zoo might have it
was then she remembered something that
made her blood run cold made the towel
drop from her hands as her stomach sank
she lived on the third floor her
apartment had no balcony no fire escape
he could have climbed up whatever was
looking at her through her window it was
no ordinary peeping Tom she couldn't say
how long she stared at the face its
unblinking eyes its inscrutable
expression she moved closer to the
window step by step until she was almost
nose to noose with the thing she
couldn't think of it as a person though
it looked like one mostly she should run
screaming out the door looking for some
kind of help but what would she say that
there was a floating face looking at her
through the window what if it was
somehow all in her head some sort of
hallucination brought on by exhaustion
and the stress of the move she raised a
fist and following a passive Instinct
wrapped on the glass she didn't know
what she expected for it to Blink to
move to knock back to say something but
nothing happened it just stayed there as
if it were part of the window window
itself Faith pulled the curtains closed
hiding the strange face from view with
any luck it would be gone in the morning
she had worked hard to get this
apartment and she would be damned if she
let some strange thing whatever it was
drive her out of her new home but as she
climbed into bed and pulled the covers
up to her chin she could still feel its
Gaze on her as if it could see through
the thick fabric of the curtains she
rolled over onto her side her back to
the window and tried her best to forget
about it to shake that horrible feeling
of being observed she lay there for
hours eyes open heart racing but finally
the exhaustion won and she Slipped Away
into sleep she didn't dream at all that
night it was as if she closed her eyes
and seconds later it was morning she
woke to the beep of her alarm feeling as
if she hadn't rested at all the first
thing she did was climb out of the bed
and go to the window carefully
tentatively she opened the curtains she
let out a sigh of deep relief the face
was gone she must have imagined it after
all a bit concerning but as long as it
didn't happen again she wouldn't have
anything to worry about lack of sleep
does strange things to the mind after
all no longer plagued by the fear of
that strange face faith hopped into the
shower and let the worries of the
previous night wash away disappearing
down the drain she brushed her teeth
dried her hair did her makeup and
dressed for work after a banana and a
quick cup of coffee she was out the door
work was exceptionally busy that day and
it pushed any memory of the Oddity in
the window out of her mind entirely she
was even feeling good enough to accept
her friend's offer to grab a drink after
work they met up at a bar down the
street from her new place sharing
cocktails memories and a plate of onion
rings it was a perfect lovely evening by
the time she got home savoring the click
of the key in the lock as she let
herself into her quiet little Sanctuary
she had completely forgotten about the
unusual Apparition she swung the door
open and rushed to dump herself onto the
couch for a bit of TV before bed then
out of the corner of her eye she saw it
the face back in its previous Place
staring at her from the darkness outside
she gasped at the sight her screamed
catching in her throat it was just as
she remembered it wait no something was
different what was it she clapped her
mouth in hor as she identified the
change its expression was different gone
was the vaguely interested neutral
expression now it was smiling at her not
a pleasant smile not a warm friendly
smile a wicked smile twisted and cruel
it knew she was afraid that she'd been
hoping it was gone forever and it was
enjoying itself her hands were shaking
nervous sweat beating on her brow what
do you want from me she whispered
staring into its eyes they didn't move
but they glittered with malicious Glee
just the same what do you want from me
she repeated her voice rising to a shout
shut up her next door neighbor yelled
banging on the wall it's after midnight
she couldn't bring herself to respond
she had more important things to attend
to her stomach turned bile rising in her
throat with a face begun again in the
morning would it come back again at
night was the apartment haunted
possessed by a spectre doomed to reside
in her window forever was that why the
rent had been so affordable or maybe it
was her maybe this thing had been drawn
to her or maybe she was losing her mind
unaccustomed to living alone and her
sanity was slipping away she shivered at
the thought what was worse if the face
was all in her head or if it wasn't
rather than attempt to answer the
question gnawing at her she closed the
curtains out of sight out of mind she
thought she would have to keep the
curtain closed possibly forever it was
better than seeing that damned face
grinning that horrible grin but as she
tried to settle in for another restless
night she could feel its eyes boring
into her burning into her skull she had
never felt so uneasy before she prepared
for cockroaches for black mold and for
burglars but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered to herself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window go to
work try to forget about the window get
home try desperately not to think about
the window she could always feel it
though as soon as the sun went down
though she kept the curtains closed she
knew it was there she thought about
checking to see what face it was making
this time but she couldn't bring herself
to look gradually her condition worsened
she woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood
the effect began to follow her out of
the apartment too far away from the fa's
dwelling she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing there
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon even her formerly
dreamless nights of sleep as fitful as
they had been became unsafe she would
toss and turn sweating through her
sheets as her subconscious was tormented
by chilling visions and terrible
nightmares she would dream of walking
down a long dark hallway that seemed to
go on forever and something coming up
behind her trying to grab her and drag
her away it would chase her wide dark
eyes and long long limbs grasping at her
as she ran and ran but never escaped
other times she would dream of being
locked in a damp basement chained to a
wall as the pale creature sat in a chair
across from her just watching waiting
for something though she didn't know
what every night another nightmare that
made her wake up screaming fighting off
invisible attackers after 2 weeks of
living in hell she decided to look out
the window again she had to see had to
know that night when she opened the
curtains it was there mouth wide open
eyes glinting it was laughing at her
screw the deposit enough was enough she
wanted her home back she picked up the
heavy lamp on her bedside table wound it
up and threw it at the window with all
her might the glass shattered little
crystalline Shard sprang in every
direction as the lamp flew through the
air out the window and down to the
street below and just like that the face
was gone she checked every other window
in place the little one in the bathroom
the people on her door but it was
nowhere to be found she was free her
knees gave out and she collapsed to the
floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living the nightmare all over again
looking out to darken window to see an
unwelcome Guest The Entity known as SCP
965 SCP 965 is a phenomenon affecting
framed windows when it appears it
manifests in the shape of a shadowy face
belonging to a pale man staring in
through the window the details of the
man's face vary from person to person as
well as his apparent age and the
direction he is facing however all
reports point to the same figure at
various ages ranging from 10 to 55 the
Foundation has attempted to use facial
recognition software to identify a
citizen matching the description of this
figure but so far no one has been found
SCP 965 will not appear in just any
window it will only manifest when the
lighting on the outside of the window
drops below illumination of five
candalas the lighting on the inside of
the window does not have any measurable
effect the face will only appear in the
confines of a completely assembled
window frame though the window does not
necessarily need to be installed sted
anywhere it will only move from one
glass pane to another if its original
point of manifestation is destroyed the
face can be seen from an outside vantage
point though it has been described by
observers as looking away into the room
when SCP 965 first appears to someone it
produces feelings of unease anxiety and
lowgrade paranoia anyone within the
visual range of the affected window will
experience these feelings even if the
window is covered by curtains or any
other means any individual that sleeps
in an area visible to SCP 965
manifestation point will begin to
experience difficulty sleeping suffering
from upsetting and disturbing dreams
however this is not the end point of the
entity's impact on those it appears to
at a point between three and 10 nights
of sleep after its initial appearance
the entity's facial expression will
begin to shift into a noticeable smile
after this shift the victim's symptoms
will become physical as well as mental
including ulcers and intestinal bleeding
heartburn abdominal pain and even
vomiting blood this has been attributed
to the entity's influence on the human
body's reaction to heighten levels of
stress and fear the subjects that reach
this stage of exposure to SCP 965 begin
to see its face in Windows in their
dreams as well as spotting it in their
peripheral vision while going about
their Waking Life they begin to see the
face out of the corner of their eye even
when the affected window is nowhere in
sight these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following or watching them
though the entity has never made a sound
and does not move while it is visible it
can disappear and reappear in different
poses it has also displayed notable
signs of sentience appearing
disappointed when it manifests in an
empty room and angry if it sees someone
who broke its previous window when
presented with one of the agents who
first brought it into custody The Entity
appeared frightened for the first time
testing involving SC SCP 965 involving
the destruction of its host window
confirmed that a multi- pained window
might act as multiple holding zones but
significant damage to its overall
structure keeps it from being a viable
replacement in this particular case the
entity manifested in a nearby
experimentation chamber observation
window which was promptly destroyed in
order to prevent any potential breaches
for a month following this incident The
Entity manifested with noticeably
hostile facial expression
clearly resentful of its treatment only
one other notable incident has occurred
so far during the course of SCP 965
containment by the SCP Foundation Dr L
the rest of her name has been redacted
from the official file was the head
researcher assigned to SCP 965 for
several months before she filed an
official request for transfer to a
different test subject she was beginning
to experience intrusive visions of SCP
965 and lingering feelings of paranoia
lasting long after after she left the
foundation's site her symptoms were
consistent with those of someone who had
slept in the presence of the entity
though she swore up and down she had
never napped or slept at all in the
vicinity of the affected window she was
temporarily relieved of her duties and
provided with psychological care so far
no other instances of SCP 965 impacting
staff who have not slept in its presence
have been reported but this case set an
unsettling precedent the mental health
of anyone assigned to SCP 96 5 is to be
strictly monitored in case it expands
its influence again SCP 965 is contained
within a framed ready to install window
made up of six panes of clear glass or
other comparable material at a size of
at least 15 cm by 30 cm the window must
be kept in an environmentally controlled
storage facility capable of withstanding
earthquakes and other seismic activity
the window must be inspected at least
once a week in order to check the
Integrity of the material
additionally at least two identical
framed windows must be stored in the
same facility in separate Chambers with
additional insulation any Lighting in
the containment chamber should be kept
at a minimum of 130 kandelas at any time
Personnel are inside with the exception
of research and experimentation though
SCP 965 is currently contained the
foundation is unable to control its
movement should its current window be
destroyed therefore SCP 965 is
classified as uid
scopophobia is the fear of being watched
or looked at by others those suffering
from this fear will often avoid Windows
terrified of who might be standing on
the other side staring in and keeping
track of everything they do even those
of us without scopophobia might find
ourselves feeling a prickle of dread
while looking out the window at night
watching for a shadowy figure or a
ghastly face pressed to the glass most
of the time of course there is no one
there it's just an overactive
imagination the lingering effect of
watching one too many scary movies but
eventually your luck might just run out
one night when the world Falls quiet and
you go to close the curtains before you
go to sleep just in case you might just
feel that someone is right there on the
other side of that thin pan of glass
staring at you with wide unblinking eyes
it won't ever come inside but it isn't
going anywhere and as long as you are
where it can see you you will never no
peace again it was November 20th 2019
and the helicopter circled far above in
the freezing wind of the Antarctic SCP
Foundation site director Jason Monroe
looked down at the isolated above ground
facilities of provisional site
[Music]
344-1314 29 mobile task force units and
73 members of d-class personnel had gone
missing here and never been found Monroe
thought he was here for a routine
investigation into negligence and
mismanagement but little did he know he
was in for so much more this is the
story of SCP
5545 and one man's journey into his own
worst nightmare literally but this
nightmare began a long time ago 300
years to be exact and like most
nightmares it started as a dream that
dream was one of EXP expion National
Powers across Europe wanted to be the
first to conquer the globe and expand
into new territories and sent countless
exploratory missions off into the
unknown to achieve this goal any history
book will tell you that the first
Outsiders to lay eyes upon the continent
of Antarctica did so in 1820 the reality
is that the first ones to get there
actually landed in the late
1700s the hapless explorers ventured
into Mainland Antarctica and made base
camps before searching into digging for
any useful resources nearby They Came
Upon a strange Discovery a hallway
hidden beneath the ice not a passage in
the ice but a true hallway complete with
light fixtures the confused explorers
ventured down into these impossible
hallways and for many of them it would
be the last thing they ever did no
matter how long they walked it seemed
like the hallways just kept going as
they continued to walk for hours they
hoped to find something anything and
eventually they did they passed from
these hallways into somewhere different
altogether and most of them were never
heard from again those who did manage to
escape often died or took their own
lives soon after whatever it was they
discovered down there they didn't want
to live with it on their minds it's
believed that over 70 Colonial explorers
disappeared or died this way and that
most who found these endless hallways
beneath the Antarctic Ice never returned
the multiple anomal objects and
phenomena that make up SCP 5545 came
into the foundation's hands several
centuries later on September 18th 2003
when during an expedition into the
Antarctic they too found the endless
hallways the foundation built
provisional site
designated as SCP
55451 and were thought to be the extent
of the anomalous activity at the site
but soon s SCP 55 45-2 was discovered
which resulted in the deaths of 16
researchers so what exactly is 55 45-2
it's an entity so volatile that even
knowing about it is considered to be a
Containment Breach and as a result it's
kept in provisional site
344-2 unlike site 344 4-1 344-2 isn't a
physical space it's conceptual
accessible only through the endless
hallways created with the express
purpose of keeping 55 45-1 and
55452 separate why because whenever the
two come into contact the result is
55453 the network of endless hallways
expanding if they remained in contact
the hallways would continue to expand
and the entire planet could be filled
with endless hallways in Just 4 to 6
hours while the two are apart though 55
45-3 reverses but it always would take
just a few hours to throw the whole
world into a chaos of infinite hallways
SCP 5545 has been given the
classification safe wait we're dealing
with a mysterious and volatile anomaly
that claimed a huge number of lives and
still somehow eludes True Foundation
understanding yet the official SCP
Foundation classification is safe how
could this be Monroe was the director of
site 58 and was the definition of No
Nonsense prior to taking the site
director position he was a decorated
member of mobile task force 8 of 10 and
helped contain numerous ker class
anomalies he'd been around the
proverbial block when it came to
anomalous activity and something about
SCP 5545 and the management of
provisional site 344 seemed awfully
suspicious to him and he had questions
like how such an unpredictable anom
could be declared safe and why had there
been such a lapse of communication
between the foundation and Dr Gabriel
Reed who'd been running the facility for
the past two decades and most of all
just what exactly was the mysterious SCP
55452 Monroe started to believe that
something terrible had happened at the
site and Reed was covering it all up but
to find out for sure he'd need to go to
Antarctica and investigate it himself
information about this supposedly safe
anomaly was highly classified those
without 05 clearance could face
termination for snooping but that didn't
scare Jason Monroe he dealt with cters
before he could deal with this or so he
thought Monroe submitted a request and
was granted unanimous approval by the 05
Council to travel to provisional site
344 and get to the bottom of this
mystery he took a chopper to the base
soon after armed with a concealed
firearm and a hostile meme detector or
hmd to test whether the base and its
staff had somehow Fallen under a
hazardous mimetic effect from SCP
5545 he'd find the answers or die trying
the moment Monroe arrived he couldn't
help but notice the strange way the
staff behaved they seemed listless
almost oppressive when he showed his
credentials to a researcher they simply
said SCP
55452 is contained in site
344-2 his request to see Dr Reed that
night was denied Dr Reed was busy he was
told wait until tomorrow tomorrow the
next day Dr Monroe met with Dr Reed but
the results of the meeting were
underwhelming to say the least just like
the rest of the staff on the site he
seemed exhausted as though he hadn't
slept in days his responses were quiet
and evasive and he refused to tell
Monroe anything that wasn't in the
official files already Monroe ran the
conversation through the hmd and found
nothing out of the ordinary what was
going on here Monroe was irritated but
not deterred nothing would stop him from
finding out the
truth the next day he flexed his 05
credentials and hacked into the B's
security system this gave him access to
cameras around scite
344-1343
D2 jackpot but when he looked at it the
feed was an entirely black screen with
the words SCP 5545 D2 is contained
inside
344-2 the footage of the staff in 3 3
44-1 was equally strange the 18
employees on site all sat at computer
banks with nothing but static playing on
their screens Monroe kept digging though
and was able to hack into the security
footage of Dr Reed's office as he
watched he discovered a 15minute period
where Reed left the office each day he
could use this brief window to break in
and collect more Intel on SCP
55452 Monroe was so wrapped up in the
investigation that he almost forgot the
more immediate danger around him and
nearly wandered into one of the Endless
hallways of
55451 by mistake he made a note to be
more careful in the future his first
attempt at breaking into Dr Reed's
office didn't produce many answers one
piece of evidence was a blurry picture
of what looked like a mobile task force
entering a 55 45-1 hallway in the dark
another was a spreadsheet featuring all
the Personnel living or dead who worked
at the site but one name and the details
of whether this person was alive or dead
was completely redacted anything
particularly juicy was hidden behind 05
clearance if Monroe wanted the answers
he needed to break through that night he
had a horrific reoccurring nightmare one
that had pled him since he joined MTF
edat 10 he dreamed that he was in a
fancy dining room with a grand fireplace
the room was full of statues of men and
women the men looked angry and the women
looked afraid as he approached the
fireplace the ceiling extended
infinitely up into the darkness suddenly
the zombie-like body of a teenage girl
appears in the fireplace hanging from a
long thread her eyes look Furious and
full of rage and Monroe somehow knows
that he's the reason for her hate when
he steps into the fireplace in this
dream she attacks him the two intertwine
and they burn forever the one difference
was that in this new iteration of the
dream he blinked upon entering the
fireplace and suddenly he was in the
hallway he woke woke sure that something
was terribly wrong here but he couldn't
give up now the next day Dr Monroe broke
into Reed's office and made a horrifying
Discovery he found files indicating that
Dr Reed was knowingly sending mobile
task forces and d-class Personnel into
the infinite hallways of
55451 to their Doom he also found
evidence that Reed and the researchers
had been spying on him somehow
intercepting copies of the notes he had
been taking that's when Dr Reed entered
the office and interrupted him Monroe
panicked and Drew his weapon holding the
doctor at gunpoint he was breaking so
many Foundation rules but right now he
feared for his life the doctor seemed
unbothered by Monroe's threats though he
told Monroe that everything was going to
plan and that he should go back to his
room Monroe was becoming increasingly
paranoid he felt that at any moment
guards might burst in and execute him
nothing about this place made sense he
worried he was going insane perhaps the
only way to find answers was to to go
even deeper to risk it all and Venture
through the endless hallways to find SCP
55452 himself and finally discover what
this thing actually was Monroe left his
room and stepped into one of the Endless
hallways of 55 45-1 that was located
just across from his dorm he found that
it was a hallway like all the others on
site plane concrete worn of age with
simple light fixtures on the walls he
walked for hours recording with a
concealed device the light suddenly went
out leaving him in complete darkness
when they flicked back on he was in a
very different environment a grand old
carpeted hallway the kind you'd see in
an old mansion he broke into a cold
sweat what was so familiar about this
place he kept walking racked with Terror
until this new hallway finally led him
to the place he'd been seeking site
344-2 the domain of
55452 it was a large poorly lit room
filled with grimacing statues and a
large fireplace at the far end it was
the exact same room from Monroe's dream
with one horrifying difference Monroe
noticed a single white thread hanging
down from the infinite ceiling and when
he looked up to find its source he
screamed there were hundreds of bodies
hanging and swinging from the ceiling
above him everyone who SCP
55452 had ever killed including MTF
members d-class personnel and even the
colonial explorers from hundreds of
years before and all of them were him
every single one they had his face and
there hanging in the middle of the room
at ground level was the body of a
teenage girl the one from his dream in
that moment he finally recognized her
she was the girl he killed the first
himy hundreds of years ago much like
Monroe you're probably wondering what is
going on here thanks to Declassified
communication between Dr Reed and the 05
Council we can tell you Jason Monroe was
a man who's been reincarnated hundreds
of times over the last 300 years ever
since he murdered a teenage girl a girl
named Emily his daughter this murder
sparked the existence of SCP 5545 as an
eternally reoccurring punishment for his
crimes since figuring this out the
foundation has kept tabs on Monroe's
reincarnations whether their MTF members
d-class Personnel or even site directors
they see to it that these reincarnations
always find their way back to 55 45-2 to
take his punishment and prevent the
infinite hallway expansion that
threatens to destroy the world it's a
plan everyone is in on everyone except
him but every time he enters that
nightmare haunting room it all comes
rushing back in that moment though he
knew his crime and he somehow knew how
many times this punishment had unfolded
for him he now had two choices repent
and accept the punishment again or leave
and activate 55
45-3 potentially allowing the endless
tunnels to expand across the world like
his many predecessors Monroe made the
decent Choice he accepted his punishment
and allowed his own string to coil
around him as the lights in the room
went off one by one leaving only
Darkness Jason Monroe that version of
him at least was never seen again but
the SCP Foundation is already eyeing up
his next reincarnation and preparing to
let this Twisted cycle play out all over
again nothing in life can prepare you
for the raw heat of a house on fire
throwing an arm up in front of his eyes
and clasping a handkerchief to his mouth
Robert chatford hacked up half of the
contents of his lungs glancing at the
material he saw that his FL was black
poisoned by the smoke a beam collapsed
in front of him sending a fresh wave of
burning air into his face so hot that it
felt like it was going to Scorch his
ears off he had to run he had to get out
of the house but he knew he couldn't his
mother was upstairs Robert barreled his
way through the Flames shouldering open
doors and stumbling along hallways the
air was so thick with smoke that he
could barely breathe so he collapsed to
the floor and started to crawl on his
stomach he reached the first step of the
grand staircase and started to heave
himself up one at a time time feeling
the heat of the house threatening to
engulf him more with every inch he
climbed but he hadn't made it more than
five steps before there was an enormous
creaking sound and the whole staircase
collapsed beneath him Sparks rushed up
into the air and swirled around the room
Flames licked at the walls all around
him as Robert looked around at the
collapsed staircase he knew that it was
hopeless with tears streaming down his
cheeks he pushed himself forward and ran
out of the house the firemen swarmed
past him filling the building and
shouting to one another but Robert just
stood there staring up at the top floor
window on the other side of the glass
surrounded by billowing smoke he looked
up at his mother sitting as she always
did on her rocking chair utterly
motionless as the house burned around
her in an undisclosed facility in the
United States of America you will find
what may well be the lowest security
containment cell in the entire SCP
Foundation
there was no heavily armored door no
bulletproof glass no machine guns about
to drop down from the ceiling at any
point in fact there's very little in the
way of containment at all they often
leave the door to the cell wide open
there is a window but on the other side
of it isn't a crowd of researchers
security guards and agents ready to
spring into action at a moment's notice
it's just a normal double glazed window
that looks out across a Vista of fields
trees and a couple of power lines facing
the window is an old armchair in which
the concrete man sits SCP
014 he spends all of his day every day
staring out of the window this view
specifically was chosen because very
little changes in it night turns to day
the trees change with the seasons and it
rains occasionally but there are no
roads no new buildings springing up
nothing to distinguish it from how it
looked in
1937 beside him is a small table home to
a record player in the corner of the
room there's an antique set of shelves
that house three dozen old records all
dated from the 1930s or earlier all day
every day the music plays out of the old
speaker every so often as researchers
walk up and down the corridor if they
hear that there isn't any music playing
they'll come into the room and change
the record over for a new one the newest
researchers check in with SCP 01 for to
see if he's okay he rarely responds and
so before long they stop asking you
would think therefore that the concrete
man is elderly approaching the Twilight
years of his life but the man who sits
there in his chair staring out of the
window and listening to music from
almost 100 years ago appears to be just
30 years old friends of Robert Chadford
reported a noticeable change in his
demeanor following the fire and death of
his mother he had lost his father not
long before to a workplace accident
William chatford had been a construction
worker climbing up the girders of New
York's emerging Skyline pouring concrete
and piling bricks he had been working on
a new building one that was said to be
the tallest in the world called the
Empire State Building day after day he
would climb the cranes Teeter
precariously over the dizzying drops any
he slight mistake and he would plummet
hundreds of feet often to the busy
streets below sh enough one day William
chatford worst fears came to life he was
walking on a gang plank that wobbled and
bent with every step he took on his
shoulders was a metal bar with a bucket
of concrete dangled precariously from
each tip he walked this route every day
but clearly that day proved too much for
the wood to take the board splintered
and split beneath him plunging him down
and down through the scaffolding William
desperately reached out an arm and
managed to grasp the edge of a girder he
hung there help lessly staring up at his
colleagues high above him he cried out
for help and upon seeing him they began
to scramble down level by level to try
and rescue him he just needed to hang on
for a moment longer and they would
rescue him but one of them knocked over
a bucket of concrete William Chadford
could do nothing but watch as the heavy
sludge slowly tumbled towards his face
he tried to dodge it but it was no use
the company told Mrs chatford that this
had been William's Saving Grace that he
had been unconscious for the long fall
down to the streets below his fellow
workers knew that this wasn't the case
they heard his screams all the way down
Mrs chatford didn't believe any of it
they were lying all of them the company
his co-workers everybody she knew what
had really killed him it was the same
thing that was killing her slowly the
same thing that had been passed on to
their son concrete poisoning she'd
approached the Wall Street Journal New
York Times and any Outlet she could but
none of them were remotely interested in
the story there were chemicals in the
concrete it wasn't safe to use it never
had been she'd been working in nursing
homes and seen the effects of concrete
on construction workers they'd become
paralyzed unable to move spending so
many years breathing concrete air
letting it absorb into their skin their
bodies had slowly started to turn into
it she knew it she started to go crazy
pinning up news clippings medical
journals photographs Maps anything she
could find all over her walls her entire
bedroom she had red string hanging from
the walls and ceiling connecting to
every surface Robert watched helplessly
from the doorway unable to do anything
as he saw his mother steadily entering
into psychosis but the further her
paranoia went the less energy she seemed
to have for it weeks went by and her
manic furor was replaced with lethargy
she got slower and slower in her
movements talked less and less at meal
times and began to sit down for extended
chunks of the day Robert assuming that
she was tired from grief did what he
could to help he carried an armchair up
to her room and placed it in the corner
by the window so that she could look out
over the world around her he thought she
was resting but it soon became apparent
that she wasn't really resting she was
withdrawing almost freezing over
desperate to try and get his mother to
re-engage with the world Robert sat down
with her to try and understand all of
her conspiracy theories around his
father's death she explained slowly and
calmly that the concrete being used in
New York was poisoned cursed she didn't
know where it had been dug up from how
it had been mixed or who was behind it
but she was getting close maybe it was
the US government maybe it was the same
witches maybe it was God himself but she
knew her husband and she knew he
wouldn't have fallen that day he had
walked across that plank thousands of
times without incident there was no way
he would have made that mistake Robert
tried to connect the dots of what she
was saying did she really think that it
was the concrete that had killed his
father she said that it was in that the
same concrete is now killing her she
showed him her hands turned them over
front and back under the light for him
to inspect they looked just like normal
hands elderly wrinkled with deep veins
popping out but normal she scratched at
them and tried to faint pain for the
effects of her fingers look she said you
see that powder coming off them that's
concrete powder but Robert didn't see
any of it the concrete man came to the
foundation's attention a couple decades
ago construction workers in New York in
the late 1990s were hard at work
clearing out the foundations for a new
skyscraper the site was built on top of
what used to be a residential block the
one Intrepid Builder soon discovered
Something That Shook him to his core
there was an old Cellar beneath where
the building used to be the lock on it
was heavy thick with rust and had been
open for close to 70 years he and his
team managed to pry it open put on their
flashlights and went inside what they
found was a basement apartment still
sitting there beneath the rubble it was
a relic of its time thick dust covered
every surface ugly wallpapers surrounded
them and ancient appliances covered with
rust sat in the kitchen it was almost
like walking through a haunted house the
builders joked about ghosts stalking
these corridors as they made their way
through until they reached the bedroom
sliding the door open they faced a man
sitting there staring at them from an
old armchair the four Burly Builder
screamed like little girls for a split
second then burst out laughing when they
realized that the man wasn't real he
must have been a wax worker something he
was sitting so perfectly still and
hadn't reacted at all to their presence
they went over to inspect what he was
made out of they tapped on his forehead
lifted his arms and dropped them and
were surprised at how convincing the
fake man was that was of course until he
politely asked them not to touch him
this time they really did scream like
girls running straight out of the
basement into a local police station
this basement apartment was where Robert
Chadford moved following the fire in his
parents home and the death of his
paralyzed mother racked with guilt he
had never been quite able to process
what had happened to cause his mother's
mental state to deteriorate so rapidly
by the time she died she had been
looking at her hands and genuinely
believing believe they were made of
concrete she would not move she would
not eat she would not sleep for days she
would just sit staring out of her window
he knew he should have taken her to a
doctor but they just couldn't afford it
maybe if he had this would have all
worked out differently Robert would
think about it hour after hour he would
sit down in the armchair in the corner
of his room and Ponder what had happened
it was difficult to keep track of time
living in the basement there were no
windows no daylight at all but he didn't
think he had had been sitting there for
very long when he noticed the skin on
his hands starting to turn gray without
Panic he slowly lifted his hands to his
eyes and inspected what was happening
his fingers down to about halfway
through his palms were dry and solid he
could move them just about but it took a
normal effort and he could see cracks
running along the back of the concrete
when he did so he decided not to he
wouldn't say he felt calm exactly maybe
disconnected he didn't feel particularly
hungry he didn't feel particularly tired
in fact he didn't feel much at all his
concrete limbs were only a passing
curiosity to him as he sat in his chair
very occasionally he would get up to put
on a record on his record player then
return to his seat and stare at the wall
that would be every couple of months at
most the rest of the time he would just
sit there one day he noticed in a vague
corner of his mind that the ground was
shaking and dust was filling the room
The Ripping sound of dynamite and the
heavy Stone just above his head told him
that the apartment block towering over
him had fallen down and almost come
through his ceiling Robert just sat
there unconcerned another day some
indeterminate time later a group of
Builders came in dressed in Peculiar
futuristic clothing with bright yellow
hats and reflective vests they seemed
rather startled to see him though in
truth he had little care for seeing them
what did perturb him was when a group of
people claiming to be Agents from the
foundation came came into his room and
carried him out he didn't like the noise
didn't like the change if he wanted to
move he would move not that he could of
course he was now entirely made of
concrete but that was beside the point
these people put him in the back of a
van and drove him across half of the
United States they wheeled him through
brightly lit rooms and into a disgusting
modern white box they had done the
courtesy of bringing his chair along and
found a new record player for him with a
whole selection of albums lining a shelf
on the wall he would have appreciated it
and said thank you to them but he didn't
really care he wasn't present at all
this was of course due to the fact that
he was made of concrete by this point
however once he was sat in his chair and
took in the site in front of him Robert
Chadford felt a dull Panic rising in his
chest they placed him at a window just
like he'd placed his dying mother in
front of a window he tried to clench his
jaw tried to move his hands tried to cry
out and in fear and pain but he couldn't
he was paralyzed the smell of smoke
filled his chest choking him torturing
him as the memories of his burning
household raged in his mind he tried to
scream he tried to fight he tried to do
anything other than just sit there but
it was far too late for any of that good
afternoon Mr chatford the researcher
said busying herself and putting on
another album for him to listen to is
there anything I can do for you sir
anything I can do to make you more
comfortable the concrete man said
nothing thing the researcher patted him
on the back of his hand made of concrete
indeed looks just like regular skin to
me Mr Chadford I do wonder what's going
on inside that head of yours on her way
out of the room she glanced at his view
from the window beautiful weather
outside today isn't it scorching even
when you work for the SCP Foundation One
certainty is that nothing no turn of
events no scenario is ever really
unexpected no matter how unlikely
something may appear chances are it
usually happens and if it doesn't happen
here then in an infinite Multiverse of
Alternatives everything that can
possibly happen is statistically likely
to we've covered a few of these
alternate eventualities before a number
of which revolve around the differing
events in the long life of one
particular anomaly SCP 076-2 better
known as AEL in our home Universe much
like he is and many others AEL is
considered to be a near perfect Warrior
his body covered in tattoos of occultt
symbols and demonic faces is capable of
withstanding vast amounts of physical
damage able can easily take hits from
the most powerful Conventional Weapons
mankind has to offer and survive with
little more than a scratch what's more
he can draw an endless supply of black
bladed weapons from a tiny pocket
Dimension and on top of all of that even
in the event that he's bested in combat
Abel's body will rapidly disintegrate
only to reform within a large Stone Cube
known as SCP
[Music]
076-2 CP Foundation as part of a mobile
task force until they turned on him this
unfurled a chain of events so
cataclysmic that the entire world
suffered the consequences this alternate
AEL went on a war path against the
foundation ultimately using SCP 914 the
Clockworks to refine his destructive
anomalous abilities this allowed him to
unleash chaos slaughtering all of
humanity in an omnicide that wiped the
world clean of all other life leaving
able alone in a dead world and then
there was this version of The Immortal
Warrior far from the Clockworks enhanced
conqueror that is alternate universe
counterpart was this AEL had long since
been removed as a member of MTF Omega 7
and was gradually reconstituting his
body within SCP
0761 his most recent defeat had enraged
the warrior and he had vowed to once
again be free although unbeknownst to
him what set this particular version of
Abel apart from his other variants was
the fact that he would soon encounter a
certain other anomaly something that
when wielded by SCP 076-2 had the
potential to completely Rob him of all
his centuries worth of fighting ability
and replace it with an embarrassment
that would last for centuries more but
first a quick history lesson much like
it had been in our universe this
particular anomalous object had been
recovered by the foundation after it
made its way into the hands of an
unwitting police officer the item in
question was SCP 572 a particularly
unique Katana unique in that it was
utterly useless for fighting with and
caused more harm to the person wielding
it than whoever they were trying to use
it against in this universe the sword
had already changed hands a number of
times when police were called to the
home of one Clarence Clancy clerson he
drew SCP 572 in defense and screamed at
the officers that he would quote take
their heads and with it their power the
cops who had been sent over to arrest
Clancy for violent and disorderly
Behavior were less than threatened to
see their suspect who was somewhat out
of shape coming at them with a weapon no
sharper than a butter knife after
pacifying Clancy with tasers and bean
bag rounds from a 12 gauge shotgun the
police retrieved SCP 572 and then it was
acquired by a foundation operative this
all played out almost the exact same way
in our universe however in this version
of events there was was one key
difference as previously mentioned SCP
572 was an unremarkable sword but it had
something of a stor past passing from
one unfortunate user to the next and
just as it was recovered from Clancy's
house and ended up in Foundation hands
one of those former owners had just been
about to reclaim the fabled weapon for
himself meanwhile back in this
containment chamber deep under the ocean
still trapped in the stone Cube he
reanimated within Abel was lost in a
dream to any other person falling asleep
to see subconscious visions of so much
Carnage would be horrifying they would
call it a nightmare but to Abel this
might have been one of the sweetest
dreams that he had ever experienced all
around him was a world on fire having
returned to life once again Abel at last
bested his captors at the SCP Foundation
in his dream he traveled the world
visiting every Foundation facility one
by one and reducing them to Rubble
without leaving a single Survivor then
once the work was done he turned his
barbarism towards the wider world and
began slaughtering Humanity in droves
perhaps some distant Cosmic Echo had
reached out across the Multiverse a
fragment of the life of a more refined
version of himself had slipped into
Abel's subconsciousness making him dream
that he too was the omnicidal Conqueror
that his other self was seeing such
Devastation in his own a wake made this
version of Abel eager to wake up to
revive once more and set about making
this delightful dream of Destruction a
deadly reality it was while Abel was
dreaming picturing himself cutting down
all who dared oppose him that something
strange seemed to happen he had a
visitor not a visitor to his containment
chamber mind you there was no one beyond
the confines of SCP 0761 except the
security team that normally kept the
stone Cube under armed surveillance no
this visitor appeared somewhere else
inside Abel's mind approaching him as he
slept within the Warriors slumbering
fantasy he was climbing up a mountain of
skulls after having slaughtered Millions
if not billions already but as he
reached the top of the pile of bones and
looked out over the horizon Abel could
see that the world Beyond was still
living there were just as many people
alive perhaps even more that he'd
already killed his work was not yet done
in fact it seemed that despite all the
lives The Immortal madman had already
claimed he had barely even begun oh able
a voice tutted did you really think you
could do it alone even though this was a
dream Abel could feel the presence of
another he pulled one of his obsidian
edged weapons from thin air and swiped
in the direction The Voice had come from
hitting nothing the blade in his hand
seemed to change its dark metal
transforming from solid to liquid coming
apart in his hands able sword melted
like candle wax under a hot flame
reduced to nothing in seconds you can't
do it the voice whispered you aren't
strong enough but I can help with that
pulling out another weapon a two-handed
axee this time able looked around him
trying to locate the source of the
taunting noise only a coward relies on
cheap tricks and Illusions he growled
angrily show yourself come forward and
be slain are you a worthy opponent are
you worth your time are you the voice
gested we shall see Abel yelled behind
him a cloak figure silently appeared
they looked to be adorned in a robe that
whipped in the biting cold wind yet
their garments weren't made of any
fabric instead they wore a robe made out
of pure Shadow their clothes and body
comprised of the same thing though they
lacked any tangible solid matter it
didn't stop Abel from spinning around
swinging his heavy axe in the figure's
direction before the blade of the weapon
was even halfway through the air it had
already started to become liquid just
like the swords had earlier by the time
it came down to strike of the shadowy
visitor what had once been an axe was
just a flick of melted black metal
passing through the intangible Spectre
as Abel found himself once again unarmed
speak Katon he demanded never one to
back away from a fight even when his
weapons were seemingly failing him tell
me who you are I would like to know my
adversary's name before I end your
worthless life I am not here to fight
you the figure replied calmly I'm here
to offer you the key to your Victory
able what key the warrior sneered what
could you possibly give me exactly what
you need to finish it the shadow replied
drawing something from a sheath on its
belt and holding it aoft a weapon that
will allow you to become the Conqueror
you long to be Abel looked at the object
in the figure's outstretched hand a
katana or at least the shadowy vestage
of one a sword he sneered what use do I
have for a sword I can conjure all the
blades I needed will to demonstrate Abel
pulled one of his own black blades but
yet again it began to melt away your
weapons have served you well but they
are disposable the shadow explained a
true warrior deserves a sword worthy of
his fighting prowess I have killed
scores of men throughout the ages The
Immortal Warrior retorted and I never
needed any special sword to do that and
that is why no matter how many you
killed you will always be beaten in his
dream Abel paused a moment looking at
the katana and considering then he
reached his hand out to grip the shadowy
hilt in that same Split Second SCP 076-2
awoke once again from his Slumber and
broke free of the stone Cube encasing
him as he killed his way through the
foundation Personnel in the facility
housing SCP e
0761 Abel had only one thought in his
mind he needed that sword you see what
the immortal Maniac was unfortunately
totally unaware of was the interesting
effect SCP 572 could have on people as
well as being a totally useless sword
anyone who picked it up will instantly
believe the katana of apparent
invincibility to be an all powerful
weapon of ancient legend despite the
sword being crudely made blunt and
generally unfit for any use the wheel
will maintain the belief that it not
only has perfect balance and cutting
power but that the sword has also imbued
them with unparalleled strength and
invincibility to damage and now either
through the sword itself extending this
Cognito hazardous influence into ael's
dream or by the interference of some
unknown trickery one of the most
dangerous and anomalous killers in the
world was making a beine straight for
SCP 572 and he wasn't the only one
either at a previous point in time a man
by the name of Zach had purchased SCP
572 on eBay but it was far more than
just an odity to him he wasn't looking
to start a sword collection as a child
he had been obsessed with comic book
superheroes and when Zach bought that
Katana he intended to use the blade to
dispense vigilante justice against those
who prayed on the innocent and even
before he held it in his hands Zack to
felt the anomalous pull of the katana
knowing in his heart it was the perfect
weapon to transform him into a hero of
course he had quickly been disproven
when on his first night of crime
fighting Zach had been hit by a midsize
sedan in a multi-story parking lot and
suffered a concussion sent to the
hospital and then charged with attempted
assault Zach had long since lost any and
all interest in ever Dawning his costume
comprised of hockey pads and a ski mask
or picking up the sword ever again but
as time had gone on that old familiar
pole had started to gnaw at Zach urging
him to get back in the superhero game
forgetting how poorly that had worked
out for him last time one problem still
stood in his way though he needed his
trusty sword back of course in the time
since he'd hung up his hero outfit
glancy had gotten his hands on SCP 572
and then right before Zach could steal
it back the foundation had taken it it
had taken him months of preparation he'd
sneakily made dealings with a janitor
that worked at one of the foundation's
sites Zach had brought the man a lot of
money in exchange for his key card and
uniform even having to take out a second
mortgage on his apartment to meet the
frankly extortionate amount the janitor
asked for but it would be worth the cost
Zach told himself if it reunited him
with his trusty Katana then it would be
worth it only then would he once again
be a full hero shuffling through the
facility Zach dragged a mop over the
floor leaving a sign to warn the
slippery Hazard he whistled to himself
trying to act as casually as possible
not realizing that he was slightly
overselling it once he was certain the
coast was clear he made his move SCP 572
was locked in a secure deposit box
within site 19's high value item storage
facility right where he had been
cleaning he began searching through the
various anomalous Oddities kept there
until he saw it the Box containing his
coveted sword all his effort in
infiltrating the foundation had finally
paid off it was all leading to this his
comeback in crime fighting it was at
this precise moment that Abel came
bursting through a nearby door
completely befuddled Zach quickly found
himself thrown to one side by the much
stronger man out of my way weakling Abel
roared before turning to face the
deposit box holding SCP 572 gripping the
Box Abel used his superhuman strength to
tear it open as though the container was
made from cardboard there it was stored
safely within was the weapon he had been
seeking the same all powerful sword from
his vision at last he declared reaching
for the hilt this sword belongs to me
the second that Abel hoisted it into the
air he felt a human weight Dash towards
him only to shrug it off as it made
impact Zach tumbled to the floor winded
as AEL barely flinched at the attempted
tackle you fool he roared you dare come
at me you'll be the first to fall to my
new Blade the first of this pathetic
world of unworthy opponents to die in my
Conquest Zach frighteningly raised his
arms in an attempt to Shield himself
when abble raised the sword menacingly
above his head the Mortal man knew what
the sword was capable of or so he
thought as Abel brought the blade
swiping downwards its true
ineffectiveness as a melee weapon was on
fold display SCP 572 is dull poorly
balanced blade barely grazed Zach's arms
as he protected his face in fact beyond
the initial SWAT it barely hurt I I
don't
understand Abel stammered looking at the
katana in confusion this is meant to be
a warrior blade a weapon of Champions
and conquerors yeah that's what I was
thinking Zach replied also suffering
from SCP 572 Cognito hazardous effect
he'd fully expected to die a second ago
slain by the very weapon he had been
hoping to reclaim still maybe it's just
because it's your first go I could show
you how to silence I will not fall for
that Abel interrupted let me see here
maybe the angle was off or how about I
use both hands here let me just once
again Abel hoisted the weapon this time
with both hands tightly gripping the
blade intending to bring it slashing
down in a big swing like a Woodsman
cleaving a log and two unfortunately as
he raised the sword the blade caught in
exposed light fixture above Sparks burst
from the ceiling as an electrical
current shot through the metal and gave
Abel a nasty shock oh God what is the
meaning of this he shouted in
frustration I've been alive for
centuries killed thousands upon
thousands of of men since the dawn of
civilization why can't I use this sword
well performance issues for a guy your
age hardly an uncommon problem Zach
joked both turned at the sound of a door
kicked open the clump of heavy boots on
the ground as a foundation security team
burst in SCP 076-2 drop your weapons in
the commander stopped mid shout wait
that's not one of his regular swords is
it sir um that's uh one of the officers
paused inside I think that's SC CP
572 attack me Abel yelled at the
foundation officers pointing the dull
tip of the katana at them if you dare
for now I will the greatest blade known
to the universe you will all fall in a
single stroke of my new weapon and once
you have fallen so shall the world SCP
076-2 able look just put the thing down
the commander urged uh trust me you
you'll thank yourself H you pathetic
fool are so afraid of the chaos I will
unleash the warrior declared such
unworthy opponents okay I've seen enough
the security Commander sighed deadly
force authorized light them up boys on
the Commander's signal a hail of gunfire
erupted bullets raining down on AEL he
slashed SCP 572 through the air certain
that what he thought was a mighty sword
could easily cut through the oncoming
bullets of course that may have been
true if SCP 572 is only real power was
not having any power at all each shot
struck Able's Center Mass barely
damaging him given his body's natural
resilience to harm particularly from
such Small Arms fire although he didn't
find it any less annoying that he
couldn't seem to properly wield his new
Katana oh are you kidding me he huffed
to himself what is with me today can't
get the hang of this thing come on a but
still a sword the weapon that will allow
me to conquer this whole world but if I
can just get the swing right calmly
knowing that the weapon itself posed no
threat even in the hands of an immortal
mass murderer the security team moved in
to apprehend AEL before they could take
the katana from his hands he dashed
towards them swiping the sword back and
forth hoping to at least hit someone to
get the ball rolling on his omnicidal
Rampage instead thanks to the influence
of SCP 572 he miscalculated took a wrong
step and slipped over on a patch of
freshly moed tile Landing in a heap next
to a wet floor sign the security team
all winced feeling the secondhand
embarrassment practically radiating off
of AEL as the ancient anomalous Warrior
lay on the floor after a spectacular
fall then one by one they all burst out
into uncontrollable fits of laughter but
while they were distracted they were
completely oblivious to Zach who emerged
from his hiding place and picked SCP 572
up off the floor he breathed to S relief
reunited with his priced weapon having
forgotten the severe injury it caused
him last time
you Abel wheezed still lying in a puddle
of mop water who are you Zach gave a
slight smile unzipping the janitor's
overalls he had on to reveal a set of
hockey pads underneath he slipped a ski
mask over his face before turning back
to Abel and replying in his most epic
voice I'm captain Katana unfortunately
his return to crime fighting would be as
shortlived as ael's own turn with SCP
572 as Captain Katana found himself hit
by a bus on his way home after trying to
use the katana of apparent invincibility
to cut set bus in half down the middle
and failing in a rather painful fashion
a shot zip past his head nearly missing
leaving an indent on the wall mere
inches away he froze peeking out from
cover scanning the area for any sign of
the enemy nothing not a single movement
but still he didn't feel the least bit
safe there was a more secure stronghold
a bunker only short Dash from where he
was squatting ripping his weapon close
to his chest private Mitchell took a
deep breath psyching himself up before
rushing across the battlefield towards
what he hoped would be better cover
ducking under a camouflag tarp that
covered the entrance Mitchell was met
with a sight of a squadmates all sitting
huddled in the Foxhole some looking
dejected and miserable others cowering
in fear all apart from Sergeant King who
sat cross-legged in one corner wearing a
permanently crazed wide-eyed stare on
his face an exhausted private Mitchell
sat down with the others unable to offer
more insight than a nod of mutual
condolence to his comrades for a while
the members of MTF Iota 17 the unit Cod
named the Greendale humans found
themselves feeling the simultaneous mix
of frightened and bored each one of them
could have achieved the same sense of
anxiety by drinking 10 cups of black
coffee loudly knocking on their drill
sergeant St in the middle of the night
then rushing back to their Barracks to
hide under their bunks movement from
outside caused the whole team's heads to
swivel peeking out of a gap in the outer
wall of the bunker they saw the enemy
immediately two of the ghostly in
corporeal figures roaming the
battlefield outside not to be
underestimated despite the baggy
oversized tactical gear they wore and
weapons that looked too big for them and
two outside meant the other three were
still out there somewhere one gave a nod
to the other instructing him to scour
the area surrounding the bunker Mitchell
was terrified and all too aware that
there were too many of them in the
bunker the enemy was bound to find them
soon all of a sudden Sergeant King
seemed to stir from his strange trance
and produced a box of matches he held
out four in his hand keeping them
covered so that nobody could tell if
they were picking a long one or a short
one the first of MTF Iota 17 private
Davis reached for a match as they were
offered his heart dropping as sergeant
King pointed it was a short one next
priv private Byron picked out a match a
long one private Mitchell's pulse
skyrocketed as sergeant King offered him
the remaining two knowing that one would
be long the other short he reached out
and plucked a short one king explained
that the First Short Straw and the first
long strong go bad luck Byron and Davis
but I don't make the rules Byron not
wanting to be at the mercy of the
spirits protested that those rules
seemed made up but private Mitchell even
less eager to go out there affirmed the
Sergeant's logic
hanging their heads both private Byron
and private Davis gathered up their
weapons and sluggishly walked out of the
bunker moments later still safe inside
private Mitchell overheard the enemy
taking fire followed by the sound of
splattering and Yelps of pain from his
two Fallen squadmates he offered a
concerned look to Sergeant King whose
wide-eyed expression was doing little to
ease Mitchell's nerves they got our
voice good King muttered rocking
slightly Tagg them like the Bowery wall
still lucky they didn't get hit by The
Cannonball Mitchell asked in disbelief
whether the enemy really had their hands
on a cannon no no The Cannonball is just
their name for it the sergeant said
solemnly I've never seen it myself but I
heard rumors apparently these
incorporeal delinquents sneak a steel
ball in with their ammo that's their way
of keeping things interesting who was it
that said war is Hell or was it War
makes people crazy crazy I was crazy
once Mitchell sighed and asked why they
don't just throw in the towel and
surrender you know darn well why the Mad
commanding officer barked chaos Mass
hysteria a whole new mess for the
foundation to clean up and you listen
here maybe you can live with that but
not me not on my watch the private asked
to be let in on the battle plan unsure
if he was more scared of Sergeant King
With the Enemy outside we should drag
one of them in here get him to give up
enemy intel King answered in a Sinister
unhinged tone he didn't respond well
when told that the intangibility of the
enemy may make holding one of them
hostage while impossible still living in
a fantasy are you private King chuckled
maniacally and didn't stop for a full
unsettling minute look I've add it up to
Here With the Enemy and their dirty
tactics I say it's time we went full
Return of the Jedi we the Ewoks and
they're the Empire now belt up and bear
out grabbing his weapon Sergeant King
suddenly hopped to his feet and bellowed
letting out a primal scream up towards
the heavens then he rushed out of the
bunker screaming his own name until a
barrage of enemy firearm opened up from
all directions still cowering in the
safety of the bunker private Mitchell
sighed again as he looked at his
commanding officer covered in splatters
of paint fortunately for Mitchell and
the rest of MTF Iota 17 the injuries
they had sustained in the line of duty
were nonfatal save for a few bruised
Egos and some stubborn paint stains on
their uniforms that took a lot of Selzer
water and lemon to wash out the
unfortunate downside however was that
their defeat led to a localized
anomalous event the perpetrators of that
that incident five ghostlike entities
with a bad habit of painting the town
red literally meet SCP
2629 sometimes more commonly referred to
as the 29-year paintball war see if you
can guess how it got that nickname
located on the outskirts of KRA out
Poland one can find an abandoned
building that was previously used as an
indoor paintballing venue but now it's
known to the SCP Foundation by its
designation of SCP
2629 inhabiting the location are a
number of incorporeal entities
collectively known as SCP
2629 these are humanoid in their shape
and behavior but largely intangible
however there are a few caveats to that
which we'll Circle back to as for their
appearance despite being somewhat
translucent facial recognition software
deployed by the foundation has
determined that these so-called ghosts
bear a resemblance to a group of five
teenagers all of whom died during a
driving accident according to local
police records these deaths took place
approximately 5 km outside of krackow
and there are no existing records that
indicate the teenagers in question ever
frequented the paintball venue while
they were alive anyway now we mentioned
not too long ago that these five
entities aren't entirely incorporeal or
at least they aren't 100% intangible the
exceptions here are the projectiles
fired from their weapons in this case
standard paintballs with no anomalous
properties remain physically tangible
they interact with the world in the same
way you would expect any normal
Paintball 2 splattering on impact with
solid matter usually a hard surface or a
human target and this exception to
intangibility also works the same way in
Reverse any paintballs fired at any of
SCP 26 29-a will have the same expected
effect any and all attempts by the SCP
Foundation to engage in Direct
Communications with SCP 26 29-a have
resulted in Failure well they will often
engage in banter and trash talk with
their opposition during games they seem
to be uninterested in talking about
anything other than paintball during one
attempt by Foundation researcher Dr Ben
kazarin to talk with the entities and
ask why they spend eternity in a
paintball Arena the only answer given by
one of the anomalous ghosts SCP 2629 a-2
was why not every afternoon at exactly
1:00 Central European Time all members
of SCP 2629 daa will manifest Within CP
2629 should they be left unattended they
will begin to roam freely often
gravitating towards the nearby
neighborhood this can lead to an event
classified as an Al 2629 scenario
however the occurrence of an a scenario
can be averted should the five entities
be engaged in a game of paintball it is
the only known measure to deter them and
as such the SCP Foundation has assigned
mobile task force Iota 17 to deal with
the problem every day all members of MTF
Iota 17 the green Greendale humans enter
the paintball facility via an
underground tunnel each of these
operatives possesses a high level of
proficiency in Marksmanship as well as
close quarters combat utilizing firearms
on top of that the foundation insists
that MTF troops in this unit also need
to be great at paintball the
foundation's MTF agents must Engage The
Five members of SCP 26 29-a in a game of
paintball shortly after the entities
manifest at 1:00 the games follow the
traditional Capture the Flag rule
wherein both teams have a flag that they
need to protect while also being tested
with securing the opposing team's flag
should the foundation's pro paintballers
be successful in winning the match then
all instances of SCP 2629 daa will Dem
manifest peacefully until they return at
the same time the following day but
should the five ghostly teammates
Prevail or if MTF Iota 17 breaks any of
the conventional paintball rules then
this will trigger an Al 2629 scenario
but exactly how long has has this
protracted paintball war been going on
for well the clue is in the nickname all
the way back in 1988 the SCP Foundation
received reports of unusual vandalism
taking place in the area near Krakow
that might have been enough to peque
their initial interest but the sudden
reported sightings of ghosts by local
civilians was what really made them take
interest descending on the small area
outside of Kau the foundation launched a
full-scale investigation into SCP
2629 given what we now know about the
anomal
it seems that with no one to challenge
them the five paintballing entities were
free to enact an Alf 2629 scenario
unobstructed once the foundation
discovered the site of SCP
2629 and determined it to be the source
of the local anomalous activity they got
to work evacuating the immediate
vicinity of the abandoned paintball
Arena and devising containment
procedures to keep unwitting civilians
from getting caught in the crossfire of
an imminent paints slinging conflict as
far as the public would know the
abandoned SCP 2629 venue was shut down
thanks to a hazardous amount of asbest
its entrances were sealed off to deter
vandals and would be Urban explorers but
in reality the foundation was keeping
people out so that the first match
between their team MTF Iota 17 and the
five members of SCP 26 29-a could
commence the battle was relentless
paintballs flying in all directions
splattering any in their path the
foundation lost a lot of good men that
day although they quickly found them
again once they cleaned cleaned up all
the paint in an attempt to shift the
tide of battle and turn the odds in the
foundation's favor MTF operatives
rearranged some of the indoor playing
field this however was an ill-advised
strategic misstep as messing with the
venue's cover violated the established
rules of paintball and doing so caused
an Al 2629 scenario to begin in response
a number of Alf 2629 procedures have
been put in place to combat the
anomalous event staff at site 19 had to
equip the protective paintballing gear
stored at their Workstation or in
lockers around the facility if any of
them couldn't access their gear the next
best thing Foundation Personnel could do
was cover their eyes and ears until the
event passed any and all delicate
equipment had to be stored for safety
purposes security staff are tasked with
making sure any scps that might be
vulnerable are kept out of Harm's Way
the foundation currently has no way of
barring SCP 2629 D's access to areas
thanks to their incorporeality however
they can be deterred by being presented
with an abundance of targets staff are
to remain on high alert until the AL
2629 scenario is over and the all clear
signal sounds with all this preparation
taking place at site 19 no less you'd
expect an alft 2629 scenario to entail
something pretty catastrophic it wasn't
always such an issue during the initial
decade following SCP 26 29's Discovery
the AL if scenario used to entail the 5
SCP 26 29-a entities roaming the nearby
area of crackout an opening fire on
people and property with their paintball
guns hardly a paint-based war crime but
definitely goes an unnecessary extra
mile in terms of vandalism then again
you try being stuck for an eternity in a
paintball Arena sometimes it's nice to
stretch the invisible space where your
legs used to be and by now you've
probably made the connection the unusual
vandalism that Drew the foundation to
SCP 2629 in the first place was the
ghostly teenage paintballers literally
Painting the Town whenever they
manifested only to fade away and after a
few hours but that's only what the a if
scenario used to entail it happened
during the 12th consecutive year of the
paintball war a third MTF loss against
SCP 26 29-8 caused yet another Al if
scenario to activate but this time
instead of roaming the local
neighborhood the incorporeal teens
Victory sent them to one of the
foundation's most highly guarded
facilities site 19 multiple unsuspecting
Foundation research Personnel were
splattered with paint the first of the
paintball wars casualties to fall
outside of a 250 M radius from SCP
2629 the foundation launched an inquiry
into how these five incorporeal
anomalies were able to breach the
security of site 19 citing loose lips
among MTF Iota 17 about site 19 as such
they were banned from ever mentioning
Foundation operations during their
paintball skirmishes with SCP 26
29-a however the lasting damage was
already done and unlike a paintball
splatter there was no wiping this away
or covering it up
every loss that MTF Iota 17 incurred in
the coming years would result in all
five of SCP 26 29-a manifesting within
site 19 celebrating their Capture the
Flag victories by committing paintball
retribution against Foundation Personnel
staff and corridors were splattered with
paint and attempts to return paintball
fire were unsuccessful in dispersing the
incorporeal attackers one researcher
even sustained an eye injury after being
struck in the eye by a stray paintball
as the years r on MTF Iota 17's losses
began to increase rapidly more and more
Al 2629 scenarios were occurring each
year Foundation facilities abruptly and
messily redecorated by a volley of
paintballs the site 19 director issued a
communic to the Ethics Committee
requesting the termination of SCP
2629 MTF iot 17 may have some of the
best trained people in the world but SCP
26 29-a have been gaining experience for
decades it was only a matter of time
before the skill Gap closed
anyone we recruit to fill a vacancy in
MTF Iota 17 is going to need to be able
to counter nearly 30 years of paintball
experience and that number is always
growing all five of SCP 26 29-a had
already gotten tired of trashing their
own neighborhood and before long they'd
similarly get bored of trashing site 19
the question was once that happened
where would they hit next nobody should
ever have to find out what a human body
smells like especially as it's being
eaten Sally clasped both hands over her
face trying desperately to block out the
smell and to trap in her nervous
breathing she couldn't bring herself to
look every bone in her body wanted to
take off running through the forest back
out onto the Interstate to try and find
some help but there was nothing she
could do she could never outrun that
thing it was too fast too Savage even if
she could convince someone on the
highway to pull over and help her they
would just tell her she was going crazy
maybe she was then the smell of her
husband's body drifted over to her on
the Wind as the crunching sound of
inhuman Jaws filled the air Panic set in
then silence she couldn't hear anything
not even a whisper in the trees had she
done it had she survived that's when a
red sneaker stepped out from behind the
tree and Sally stared into the eyes of
the blood spattered Hedgehog now Sally
had never been a gamer growing up sure
she played a little bit of Mario Kart
and had a few nintend dogs back in the
day but the word gamer just wasn't for
her however love conquers all and when
she found the man of her dream she
decided that it would be worth at least
giving some of his Hobbies a go they
started off nice and easy playing a bit
of stardew Valley Minecraft and maybe
some overcooked here and there but
before long the pair of them were
sitting down every day after work
headsets on and controllers in hand
ready to dive into the latest Adventure
just recently the couple had gotten into
Retro games going back and playing
Classics like battle toads and Streets
of Rage the challenge was addictive so
when her husband John came home with a
copy of an unmarked NES game Sally was
intrigued to say the least John
explained that he had found it listed on
eBay Bay under a very suspicious account
he had gone to pick up the game after
work that day expecting to be greeted by
the smiling face of the cellar instead
he found a blank gray cartridge and a
very brief manual wrapped together with
an elastic band on a street corner the
seller had listed it for virtually
nothing and based on the description
seemed very eager to get rid of the game
for some reason so eager that he must
not have wanted to stick around to even
hand it over Sally Bard with this
backstory snatched the manual up and
read the title of the game Professor
Gould's terrifying horror challenge
there was no artwork no branding no
publisher no stickers nothing to
differentiate this game from being just
a blank cartridge as far as Sally knew
it could have been a virus some kind of
malware game designed to Brick their NES
but the words horror and Challenge from
the title sold her she blew on the pins
and the C cartridge and slotted it into
place in the NES a black screen appeared
with nothing on it but two options
single player or two-player Sally
uncoiled a second controller and handed
it to John with a grin you ready Sally
hit two-player and a new screen came up
are the people holding the controllers
the people who want to play the game yes
or no Sally hit yes a shrill beep filled
the room high-pitched and grating on
their ears John immediately grabbed for
the remote and turned the volume down on
the TV but the beep just kept going the
screen was a bright red filling the room
with an unnatural bloody light Jon tried
to hit the off button on the remote but
the TV stayed red and the beeping sound
continued filling their tiny apartment
getting up and rushing over to the TV
Jon tried to unplug it but it was no use
the beeping noise and the red screen
persisted he looked back at his wife in
confusion but she was looking somewhere
else entirely there was a rat in the
corner of the room with muddled fur
bloated flesh and cracked teeth it
stared right into Sally's eyes
salivating without a moment's hesitation
she leaped up onto the couch and
screamed but instead of running away the
rat slowly crept forward looking almost
as if it was smiling then a second one
appeared crawling out from behind the
couch followed by third in the doorway
and a fourth beneath the TV dozens of
rats filled the room swarming in from
all directions climbing over one another
in a desperate attempt to get into the
tiny apartment to get to Sally and John
Sally clambered onto the couch with her
laptop and tried to kick away any of the
rats clambering up onto the furniture
but it was no use for every rat she
kicked away another one appeared until
soon they were climbing their way up
Jon's Jean
their sharp little claws digging into
his flesh the rats tore at Sally's
clothes climbing over one another
desperately heading towards her mouth
trying to burrow their way in hairy
bodies filled her vision and the stench
of disease made her gag seizing an
opportunity a rat tried to clamber
through her open Jaws she felt its Tiny
Paws scrabbling at her tongue with tears
filling her eyes she took one fleeting
look at the man she loved and noticed
something behind him a giant Yellow
bottle with the words rat poison stamped
into the side was sitting precariously
on top of their cabinet half stumbling
half swimming Sally pushed her way
through the throng of rats filling their
apartment and desperately grabbed the
bottle from on top of the cabinet
throwing the rats off her hands she
managed to unscrew the lid held the
bottle High over her head and poured the
thick stinking liquid all over the swarm
of rats threatening to engulf her the
chorus of death filled the room whether
it was the sound of the rats dying or
their bodies being evaporated by the
poison she couldn't tell all she could
do was push through to try and find her
husband and save him too and
miraculously within just a few seconds
all of the rats had disappeared the room
was empty the same as it had always been
even the big yellow bottle was gone from
her hand all she could do was stare at
John as he stared back at her as the
words level one one complete appeared
above their heads welcome to SCP
1315 the most visceral most real and
most dangerous horror game you will ever
have The Misfortune of playing it's not
too late to back out at the menu screen
when you select how many players you
want it's not even too late at the
confirmation screen but once you're in
the game there's no turning back either
you beat the game or you die I trying
beating this game is no easy feat a copy
of SCP 1315 has been in Foundation
containment since 1986 but in all of
that time only one d-class personnel has
managed to make it to level 33 it is not
known how many levels there are but
there is theoretically a final boss the
reason why no one has been able to beat
it thus far is that with each level the
difficulty of the game increases
relatively minor challenges in the first
few levels give way to extremely
difficult life-threatening scenarios as
the player progresses these levels
broadly follow the same pattern each
time but individual levels often contain
an element of Randomness for example
level one that Sally and John played
contained rats but other tests have
shown subjects being swarmed by insects
and spiders often coinciding with
established phobias that the subject has
reported prior to The Experiment 2 hours
later John and Sally were running low on
ammo with both couches pushed against
the door to the lounge they both
hunkered down behind the TV loading the
remains of their shells into the
shotguns from out in the hallway they
could hear the heavy footsteps of more
animals rushing towards them when the
pounding on their door had first started
they assumed it had been their neighbor
coming up to complain about their
screaming and running around in the
previous levels John had been so deep in
thought trying to work out what their
cover story could be that when he opened
the door and saw an adult grizzly bear
standing on a Time legs in front of him
it had taken him almost too long to
react sprinting back into the lounge he
found his wife already loading rounds
into the shotgun that had suddenly
appeared on the floor in front of her
with a grim expression on her face she
seemed to have accepted their new
reality that this was a game they were
going to have to fight their way through
but with every bear they shot as it
tried to push its way into their Lounge
two more had appeared just minutes later
while they had been conservative with
their ammo aiming for the heads and not
taking any risks the pair was starting
to run dangerously low was there an
objective they were missing were they
supposed to have done something to
progress through the level Sally mashed
a couple buttons on the NES controller
and then some text appeared on the red
screen objective survive four Bears
appeared in the doorway and pushed hard
against the couch it slid out of the way
and they charged into the room Al and
John desperately took down the first two
of them but the dreaded click of the
triggers told them they had nothing left
closing their eyes and bracing
themselves for the worst the pounding of
heavy paws on their vinyl floor suddenly
stopped the Bears had disappeared level
three complete well whatever's next
can't be worse than that surely but it
was they managed to hold out in their
apartment until Level 9 but then the
windows behind their heads smashed into
a thousand shards as a black booted SWAT
team swung into the room with barely any
time to react Sally and John pushed
their way out of the apartment and
braced themselves down to their car
slamming both doors closed they took off
racing towards the highway as the SWAT
vehicles pursued them 3 hours later the
couple was running low on gas swerving
their way along the interstate their
eyes on the mirrors constantly the pair
was pretty certain they'd managed to
lose their as salant slowing their car
to the speed limit they gently weaved
their way through the the traffic
towards the nearest gas station trying
their best not to look suspicious the
two of them went inside Keen to stock up
on supplies who knew how long this game
would go on for they had already been
active for hours and were exhausted with
the SWAT team hopefully long behind them
now the adrenaline rush was starting to
wear off and the reality of this
situation was starting to set in
hopefully there were just 10 levels and
they only had one to go with the sinking
feeling in their chests each one of them
realized it was more than likely to be
100 definitely time to stock up on some
supplies they were barely Halfway Around
the gas station when the words level 9
complete flashed in the sky above them
both John and Sally froze where they
were and stared at each other over the
aisles a blue flash started past them
outside the windows then again going the
other way Sally ran over to the counter
and banged on the glass lock the door
lock the door but the teenager just
looked at her in confusion and now now
it was Sally's turn to look around and
see her husband staring in horror on the
other side of the glass standing between
two gas pumps was
Sonic.exe with haunting red eyes rows
and rows of sharp teeth and blood
dripping from his mouth the Hedgehog
stared intently Sally pointed out the
window and turned to the teenager
yelling but the girl took a step back
looking scared of her the girl couldn't
see it she couldn't see Sonic for all
these challenges all the things they'd
been fighting was it just in her head
but there was no time to worry about
that Sally ran towards the door to the
back of the shop hearing the footsteps
of her husband running after her she
kicked open the fire exit but froze
immediately Sonic.exe was standing there
in front of her smiling it was toying
with them they needed to run to get out
of here as quickly as possible but how
could they outrun Sonic hey Sonic Jon
yelled from behind her yeah hungry he
pushed Sally out of the way and threw a
handful of chili dogs out into the
forest hearing hungry Sonic spun around
and chased after his favorite food as
quickly as possible that had only bought
them a few moments of time but maybe
that was all that they would get Sally
and John ran back through the
convenience store and out the front they
couldn't run but they could at least try
to hide a semi- had a slam on the brakes
as the pair of them ran across the
interstate without a choice of running
anywhere else all they could do was D
into the woods on the other side and
hoped that Sonic had a bad sense of
smell but as they ran through the woods
they could hear an ominous voice echoing
behind them got to go fast got to go
faster than that Sally found a tree and
dived into cover just at the right
moment her husband wasn't so lucky there
was a flash of blue and a horrible
crunching sound before his body hit the
ground Sonic.exe was on top of him in a
heartbeat rows of sharp teeth nashing
Sally clasped both hands over her face
trying desperately to block out the
smell and trap her nervous breathing she
couldn't bring herself to look every
bone in her body wanted to take off
running through the forest out onto the
road to try and find some help but there
was nothing she could do she could never
outrun that thing it was too fast too
Savage even if she could convince
someone on the highway to pull over and
help her they would just tell her she
was going crazy maybe she was then the
smell of her husband's body drifted over
to her on the Wind as the crunching
sound of inhuman Jaws filled her ears
new tears flowed then silence she
couldn't hear anything not even a
whisper in the trees had she done it had
she survived then a red sneaker stepped
out from behind the tree and Sally
stared into the eyes of the blood
splattered deranged Hedgehog Sally
blinked and it was gone level 10 then
complete the open Forest stretched out
in front of her without a moment to
catch her breath Sally took off running
into the country on her own whatever was
coming next she had to be ready for it
the Shinobi crouched low on the pagota
roof and listened to the night air up
here in the mountains away from the
hustle and bustle of the markets in town
it was almost silent just the distant
rattle of shutters somewhere behind him
the mountain Shrine was tucked out of
sight so far into the countryside that
no one would stumble onto it by accident
no one would come here without a reason
the Shinobi knew the face of his Target
a warlord turned politician with more
blood on his hands than the Assassin
sent to kill him by the burning glow of
the night sky the Shinobi could see the
man kneeling at The Shrine the path was
made up of small stones so he'd have to
drop onto the grass and creep around the
pond to approach his Target no guards no
one else was there at all this was the
spot where the man came to pray when he
was struggling to sleep perhaps trying
to atone for the lives he'd taken
perhaps he didn't care at all the ninja
drew the blade in total silence and
timed his drop to the ground with the
rattling noise in the distance with each
dainty step he closed the distance to
his Target readying the blade over his
head it was done in a moment the man was
dead before his body Body Hit The Ground
he likely didn't even notice as the
steel had severed the nerves running
down his spinal cord so shred was the
blade that had slid through his bones
like a fish through water raising the
blade to his eyes the Shinobi cleaned it
quickly if he was seen with blood on his
sword he would immediately be implicated
not that he was ever seen But
precautions like this were what kept him
out of sight for all these years when
you lived in The Valley Of Ashes the
burial grounds for countless War
you had to become a shadow become one of
the ancient Spirits haunting the woods
but as he wiped the red from the steel
he caught a flash of light in the
reflection an orange glow marking a
jagged line across the mle that's
strange Sunset was several hours ago
come to think of it why was there an
orange glow in the sky he snapped his
neck around to see the fires through the
gates into the pagodas garden down by
the Ocean's Edge at the foot of the
mountains was the the city where he had
always lived and it was on fire leaping
up onto the walls he stood up straight
surveying the horror scene taking place
before him thick plumes of smoke
billowed up into the night sky so dense
and large that it seemed to become the
Blackness of the night it was hard to
make out much of what was going on down
there the Shinobi looked everywhere to
try to see the invading army or the
rioter but there were none just people
running in all directions like a an out
of a flooding Nest but there moving in
amongst the smoke were other shapes
impossibly tall lumbering around like
people people that towered over the
houses that had to Crane down to the
ground to scoop up the poor civilians
who were running this way and that the
Shinobi stood there terrified as he
realized that the rattling sound he'd
been hearing all night wasn't from any
shutters at all he could do nothing but
watch as the trees in front of him
trembled and buckled in all directions
as a hulking shadowy figure lumbered
towards him the Imperial Japanese
anomalous matters examination agency or
the
ajaa was a Japanese agency responsible
for tracking a number of mysterious and
often dangerous artifacts creatures and
anomalies prior to the second world war
in 1945 the IGA was shut down and
absorbed into the SCP Foundation all of
these data historic records and
anomalies were all transferred over into
the foundation's control reasons for
this were partially political and
partially in the interest of world peace
the formation of the mmea was influenced
heavily by Japan's ties with Germany in
the first half of the 20th century the
Imperial German anomalous matters
examination agency was the blueprint for
their Japanese equivalent however with
increasing militarism in Japan
throughout the 20th century the mmea
became increasingly obsessed with trying
to harness their anomalous discoveries
in the the interests of military power
their goal became the establishment of a
yo-kai battalion powerful enough to
establish them as one of if not the
world's greatest superpower following
the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
Japan surrendered in the second world
war and agreed to dissolve its military
including the a mea that left the
foundation with the task of picking up
the threads left behind and trying to
come up with new ways of securing
containing and protecting some of
Japan's most deadly scps few more deadly
and evasive than the entities that were
too much even for the yo-kai Battalion
SCP
2863 in 1946 cleanup operations were in
full effect trying to deal with the
Fallout from the atomic bomb dropped on
Nagasaki Crews dressed in leadline suits
worked Around the Clock burying
radioactive material and trying to
remove as much contaminated debris as
possible rebuilding the city was still a
long long way off at various points the
wind would kick up and carry the dust
Left Behind into the air creating a
dangerous radioactive Haze Crews
continued to work through such
conditions as the understanding of
Airborne contamination was still in its
infancy wanabi Goro was one such worker
Midway through a night shift and
clasping a damp rag to his mouth he
pushed on through the dust clearing out
building after building they had spent
the morning carrying corpses out of an
unidentifiable building the corpses
themselves were pretty much worn away
too just skeletons really charred by the
blast from months before as Goro
staggered along the street he kept
feeling like he was imagining things the
long hours and traumatic conditions were
enough to make him see all kinds of
things in his dreams but he kept feeling
like his dreams were starting to creep
into the real world Shadows kept moving
through the haze all around him taller
than buildings staggering around as if
they were drunk they had been been
appearing all night just out of sight
but always close by he stopped and
leaned against what was left of a brick
wall there was one of his hallucinations
now just up ahead of him the husks of
buildings on either side of him were
about as tall as their knees it must
have been 30 m tall at least but its
legs were strange there seemed to be a
gap in the middle of each of them they
were skinny no skeletal the skeleton's
foot crushed a car right in front of him
the crunch of metal was loud enough to
snap Goro out of his stuper this wasn't
a hallucination hallucinations can't
crush cars with a Yelp he tumbled
backwards staring up into the haze of
dust he saw the shape of a pelvis above
it what must have been a rib cage the
size of his house but the creature
disappeared into the darkness and the
dust if it was too tall for him to see
its face maybe it was too tall to see
him on the ground as well the skeleton
stopped standing directly over him for
for a second he thought that maybe he'd
be okay but then with a great rattling
Rumble the monster hunched down low and
the enormous skull appeared out of the
haze flying right towards him he managed
to dodge its nashing teeth but it caught
his foot sending him rolling through the
radioactive dirt Goro didn't give
himself a moment to recover though he
took off running as fast as he could
hearing the rattling sound terrifyingly
close behind his back you will be
pleased to know that wanabi Goro
survived D this incident with only minor
injuries he managed to navigate his way
to the nearest police station where SCP
agents already familiar with the entity
he had encountered took control of this
situation the so-called starving
skeletons had been roaming the bomb
sites for several weeks by that point it
was the foundation's first exposure to
one of the oldest known entities that
the amea had been studying for years to
date 206 separate instances of SCP 2863
have been off officially recorded
however the myth of the gasha doru had
been circulating in various parts of
Japan since the 10th Century at least
giant skeletons were said to haunt the
sights of particularly deadly battles
hunting by night and feeding on the
blood of their human victims these myths
tally up with what the foundation
currently knows about these entities
instances of SCP 2863 only appear after
Sunset and will lose all Corporal
reality when exposed to sunlight in the
morning or any light source over 1.1
luck to give you some reference for that
Moonlight typically Falls between .25
and 1 Lux a typical room with the light
on will be 100 or even 1,000 times
brighter as you can imagine this has
made them virtually impossible to
contain as they manifest and unmanifest
outside of controllable conditions they
seem to have continuous existence in
some way however as previously
neutralized instances can and will
reappear later on on in folklore the
gashadokuro are spirits that take
control of skeletons some hesitant
researchers have posited that perhaps
the instances that dematerialize are
returning to their Spirit form little is
understood about what that means in
practice what's more this SCP cannot be
photographed all attempts to capture
them on film or digital cameras have
failed including video tests it is
theorized that there is a link between
them not appearing on camera and their
disappearing when exposed to light again
the link between them is still mostly
unknown due to a steady increase in
urban development in Japan and ongoing
peace in the region appearances of this
SCP are growing increasingly rare while
this marks a positive change for the
people of Japan it makes it even more
difficult to study this SCP and learn
how to prevent it in the future the most
recent fatality to occur at the Bony
hands of SCP 2863 happened in 2008 and
it was part of a Foundation experiment
While most of Hiroshima and Nagasaki had
been redeveloped into bustling
metropolitan areas the outskirts of each
City particularly several Parks saw
occasional instances of SCP 2863
appearing at night as such the SCP
Foundation conducted a series of
experiments under cover of Nightfall
releasing d-class Personnel into a park
in Hiroshima to observe how the scps
hunted humans their enormous height
towering at over 30 m gave them a hugee
Advantage being able to chase people
down with little difficulty another
notable thing about them is just how
quietly they move there is a gentle
rattling sound that follows them around
but aside from that they are very lightf
footed and difficult to detect until
they are right on top of you this isn't
helped by the fact that they hunt at
night as a result they are remarkably
quick at catching their prey once they
have snatched their victims up in their
skeletal fingers they perform the same
eating ritual every time they eat the
person and consume their blood initially
confused by this finding the foundation
was unsure where the blood was going as
the skeletons had no obvious digestive
system after the release of several more
d-class Personnel into the park they
still weren't certain but they believed
that the SCP instances were absorbing
the blood into their bones in some way
further testing was requested but denied
due to the sheer number of d-class
fatalities in the area they were
starting to run out and was have to ship
more of them across to Japan which was
just a bit inconvenient for everyone
involved as the outskirts of those
cities have been urbanized the instances
of SCP 2863 have reduced to the point
that a smaller contingent of agents and
researchers are now left in place the
light pollution from these areas is
enough to prevent them from being able
to manifest in the first place for the
most part only on the rare occasion of
power outages have mobile task force 03
been deployed whilst researching the
this SCP the foundation came across an
account from a Shinobi in the 1700s it
was rare to find any kind of written
document from a ninja for obvious
reasons but the account discovered
painted a harrowing picture of just how
much damage these yo-kai could inflict
upon a city the nameless Shinobi first
encountered SCP 2863 while assassinating
an unnamed Target in the mountains above
his fishing Town looking down on the
fires below him he saw human shapes
walking through the smoke dwarfing the
building they move between before an
instance charge through the trees
straight at him diving out of the way
the Shinobi quickly melted into the
Shadows both man and Demon hunted one
another throughout the night he managed
to climb onto its spine and inflict what
he was certain would be a killing blow
to the skeleton only for his blade to
bounce right off the bone caught and
vulnerable for the first time in his
life the shenobi was helpless as the
spirit threw him from its back into the
courtyard and charged at him it was only
that the Hem of the Ninja's sleeve
Catching Fire from a candle that saved
him just as the skeleton was about to
bite down on his head the light flared
and the SCP disappeared entirely for a
long while the man lay in the courtyard
pondering his actions he should have
died that night yet he survived getting
slowly to his feet the man now knew what
his Destiny was a monster that strikes
from the Shadows scared of the light he
and the gashadokuro were not so
different understanding his Target was
the first step to defeating them
snatching up a lantern from the ground
the Shinobi descended the mountain into
the wreckage of his H toown and defended
his people by night he would emerge
hunting down the gashadokuro under the
cover of Darkness banishing them with
the light hidden under a dark sheet the
man fought night after night narrowly
risking death to save his people from
the onslaught of the evil spirit a small
plaque was installed by the AA shortly
before the foundation took over the
management of the SC P it was installed
at the foot of an old pagota just
outside a small fishing Village on it
was a simple Haiku walking in Shadow in
the midst of our demons we will find the
light a veteran worker of the SCP
Foundation sits at his terminal
performing one of the most critical
tasks in the entire organization
creating a file for an as yet
undescribed SCP but there's something
terribly wrong his eyes are glazed over
his m mouth hangs open is this a zombie
or a trained Foundation
researcher what is going on like any
large International Organization it
takes more than just the exciting action
filled jobs to keep the wheels turning
at the SCP Foundation sure the head
researchers guards mobile task force
soldiers and members of the 05 command
get all the praise but a legion of
number crunchers cleaners and paper
pushers are equally important one such
person was archist Walter ban mbridge
who had been tasked with digitizing some
of the older records that the foundation
had on file it was when he was
innocently recording the details on SCP
050 through
060 that he first came under the strange
and startling effects of SCP
055 but the most peculiar part as with
all incidents of SCP 055 anomalous
effects taking hold is that Walter had
no idea any of it was happening in his
new digitized filing system he first
took note of SCP 053 uclid class also
known as the young girl this anomaly was
a seemingly normal human female child
who provoked homicidal Insanity in those
directly exposed to her then SCP 054
safe class a non-aggressive humanoid
female made entirely of as well as
biologically and chemically identical to
regular Spring Water next SCP 056 uclid
Class A being that changes form to suit
its environment but only when all
observers lose focus of it and then SCP
057 safe class an underground chamber
that crushes the humans who walk within
it was at this point that Walter
received a concerned message from one of
his superiors at site 19 Mr kovat the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of SCP
055 immediately Walter was embarrassed
how could he have forgotten SCP
055 that iconic anomaly known for well
he couldn't quite say off the top of his
head but he'd be sure to look into it a
quick trip to the site9 archive showed
him that there was actually quite a
hefty file on the nature of SCP
055 which must have been the result of a
huge number of studies what struck him
as strange was that all the files were
filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these notes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after writing in an almost
trans-like State he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on SCP
058 a giant evil Bine heart with insect
legs and a scorpion Stinger strange he
thought that's when Walter got a call
from Mr kovat on his foundation issue
phone and he didn't sound happy he'd
given Walter direct instructions to go
back and digitize the files on
055 and instead he'd been working on 058
what was the meaning of This Walter was
typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering
talking back jce once and hoping it
didn't get him demoted to d-class and
thrown into 682s Acid Bath for playtime
Walter G picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what SCP 055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence uh of course I
can tell you about SCP
055 it's a classic one of the first h
how could you forget it's uh or you know
it's I think it's the one with um
another long pause as Mr kovat seemed to
search for the words but instead just
trailed off into silence knowing that
some of the anomalies on file were
dangerous mimetic hazards Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have
accidentally killed his boss by getting
him to think too hard about SCP
055 he asked if Mr koven was okay and
finally got a reply I'm sorry I seem to
have zoned out for a second there what
were we talking about again but this
time it was Walter who couldn't answer
he had no idea at all what the two of
them were discussing just moments ago he
felt disoriented and kind of sick like
they'd taken some low-level amnestics Mr
kovat told Walter to get back to his
filing duties and they'd speak later
Walter then checked the messages he'd
received from Mr kovat earlier and there
it was plain as day you miss
055 go back and digitize that before
proceeding Mr K but Walter had never
even heard of an SCP 055 if such an
anomaly even existed what was going on
here in that moment Walter realized he
was dealing with something much Stranger
Than Just a standard digitization job
after all how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP 055 seemed to be
impossible to speak write or even think
about unless you were were directly
observing it at that moment Walter had
to know and ask around the entirety of
site 19 to find the answers if he had to
sadly for Walter he was about to embark
on a much more challenging task than he
could have ever imagined to paraphrase a
supposed quote from Socrates all I know
is that I know nothing and that's also
about the extent of the knowledge we
have on SCP
055 also known as the anti-em and the
self- keeping Secret what does it look
like when and how was it obtained by the
foundation what are its anomalous
abilities is this thing dangerous we may
never know because the only anomalous
ability of SCP 055 that we're aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of
retaining any information about it it's
crucial to note that whatever 055 is it
isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seemed to
spontaneously erase themselves hence the
self- keeping secret but this didn't
deter Walter perhaps his greatest
Advantage was that he didn't know enough
about the thing he was investigating to
know how futile his mission was he
wanted to know the unknowable and a
pesky issue like impossibility wouldn't
stop him he'd get to whoever he needed
to at sight 19 to get the answers he
needed of course most people had no
knowledge of the mysterious anomaly the
common response he got back from his
colleagues was 055 do we even have a 055
while the realization of sudden memory
loss or the realization of 055 existence
has been known to cause momentary stress
there are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from 055 anomalous
abilities it's a fleeting idea in its
purest form like forget for getting why
you walked into a room 055 could be the
most harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know at times Walter worried
he was going insane 055 and everything
related to it was gaslighting him was
055 even real the one thing that proved
to him that 055 must have existed is
that its containment chamber existed
according to the official records kept
by the foundation on the site 19
containment facilities 055 is kept in a
5x5 by 2.5 M Square Room constructed of
50 ft thick cement with a faraday cage
surrounding the cement walls the report
continues that access is via a heavy
containment door measuring 2x 2.5 M
constructed on bearings to ensure door
closes and locks automatically unless
held open deliberately 055 cell is one
of the few to have no posted security
guards and any Personnel working on
other scps in the area are ordered to
remain at least 50 ft from the geometric
Center of 055 cell where the anomaly
itself is kept when he tried to explore
further why the cell was constructed in
this manner he found that surprise
surprise nobody knew 055 was an anomaly
whose containment requirements were so
mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a ker class designation after all
how can you properly contain something
you can't even hope to comprehend there
were plenty of rumors about the true
nature of
055 some of the more conspiratorial
Minds at site 19 theorized that 055 was
actually an autonomous or remotely
controlled spy inserted into the site to
observe Foundation operations or even
Humanity as a whole if you're on the
more paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John marich were two scientists that
had performed extensive research into
and who Walter hoped might have the
answers he sought about the self-
keeping secret these scientists were the
first to discover the anti-mimetic
nature of 055 performing numerous tests
on d-class Personnel to see if it was
possible to create feasible written
records sketches or any other records or
Impressions that could bypass its
anomalous effects the disorienting
memory ruining effects of 055 also
extend to any materials concerning 055
it seems to be a truly uncrackable code
but Dr Hughes may have finally found
some cracks in the armor for starters
the fact that we're able to remember
that 055 is an anti-mimetic is an ironic
exception to its antimimetic qualities
this Revelation also inspired another
realization from Dr
Hughes would it be possible to discover
more about 055 from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about 055 by figuring out
all the things it isn't rather than what
it is Dr Mar designed an experiment with
Dr Hughes to explore this Theory they
designed the experiment around a simple
question is 055 not spherical in
designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn't they hope to
subvert the anomaly's anti-mimetic
powwers Walter was fascinated by this
potential method of getting answers Mar
and Hughes found that while the
questioning process for those exposed
was often arduous and frustrating they
could now definitely say that
055 is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
055 by an almost endless barrage of
deductive questions though whether
command would authorize the resources
for such extensive testing is still an
open question Walter and his desperation
begged marich and Hughes for clearance
to view 055 himself the Curiosity had
become too great during his search to
just walk away with the single fact that
055 was in spheral he needed to see this
thing and after several weeks of filling
out forms and cutting red tape his wish
was finally granted Walter Banbridge was
allowed a private audience with SCP
055 the subject of his month's long
Obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
pneumonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-mimetic effects
of the self- keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his nonspherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr kovat would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type SCP 059
ker class this anomaly is a radioactive
mineral that emits a unique radiation
known as Delta radiation exposure to
this radiation has caused strange fungal
growths on the
infected wait what was this supposed to
be about again oh well it couldn't have
been that important researcher Martin
pushed the deck against the door hoping
it would hold long enough for him to
find an alter alternate Escape Route he
wasn't thinking about the long term he
couldn't afford to with the foundation's
global reach he'd never truly Escape
them never be able to make it away
condemned to spend the rest of his life
on the run from the organization he
devoted his life to it was too
overwhelming to even attempt to reckon
with that especially with the pounding
of a fist against the door he scrabbled
around opening Windows to try and see if
there was a safe way down technically
none of this was his fault at least in
his mind the administrative login
information he'd used to access the file
shouldn't have been left so easy to find
that was just poor cyber security on the
foundation's part researcher Martin had
been tasked with compiling information
on SCP 001 one of the most infamous
anomalies ever encountered in the
foundation's long and storied history or
multiple of them at least what Martin
had come to learn was there were
numerous entities within the
foundation's files that all acted as
proposals for SCP 001 some were
creatures the typical kind of anomalous
entities the foundation dealt with on a
regular basis but some of the proposals
focused on more abstract anomalies and
somehow those were more existentially
terrifying than any evil Godlike being
bent on destroying reality theories
about the very source of anomalies
themselves that their very existence
might have been predetermined by some
other worldly Force then there were the
other proposals that named parts of the
foundation as the true
scp1 those seem to suck researcher
Martin in like a Vortex dragging him
down a deep dark rabbit hole that made
him start to question everything he
thought he knew about working for the
SCP Foundation and the one that had
toppled him into a full-blown conspiracy
obsessed stuper that there was no coming
back from the Noir box proposal the
weighted head of a battering Ram
splintered the wooden surface of the
door spraying fragments over the room
the table propped up to keep it shut
toppled under the force of the entry as
a squad of shadowy figures in full black
combat gear rushed inside the mobile
task force surrounded the cowering
researcher keeping their weapons trained
on him researcher Martin pleading for
his life started gesturing to the walls
of the room around him that had been
plastered with hastily scrw diagrams and
equations Martin tried desperately to
find some concise easy to understand way
of explaining to the soldiers what he'
uncovered they only picked up on a few
words like many worlds hypothesis and
splitting universes but ultimately they
didn't follow what he was saying and
weren't sent there to hear him out all
the MTF had been told was that
researcher Martin had breached
Foundation security and now posed a risk
of exposing sensitive information about
SCP 001 there was only one path of
recourse termination however unbeknownst
to them Dr Martin was fine at least a
version of him was one who never learned
about the Noir box proposal for
scp1 and hadn't gone mad trying to
unravel its Mysteries instead he was a
respected higher ranking member of the
foundation who was alive and well in a
completely different timeline the
formation of the SCP Foundation has
always been shouted in mystery with
nobody really knowing what the true
origin of the organization is and what
is merely just a cover story left in the
archives to keep the truth hidden SCP
001 the Noir boox proposal at least
might hold the answers to the questions
surrounding how the foundation came to
be three times over known as the
tindalos Trinity the file pertaining to
this anomaly is buried deep in the SCP
foundation's database under layers upon
layers of encryption and security
clearance requirements it requires
someone at the very top level of the
foundation to access a member of either
the overseer Council or the foundation's
high command or OverWatch but wait what
are those aren't they the same thing
well yes and no the exact name of the
high-ranking secretive group that runs
the foundation has often been
interchangeable whether they're known as
the 05 Council the overseer Council Etc
but what if it wasn't just many
different names for the same governing
body but actually separate names for
alternate versions of the ones who
control the CP foundation allow us to
explain all three of these groups the
overseer Council High command and
OverWatch have come to a consensus that
SCP 001 is an anomaly that connects with
the foundation's very origin they
believe that the founder of the SCP
Foundation also known as SCP 001 was
anomalous in some way that caused them
to interact with time in an unusual
fashion the trium of councils are in
agreement that around around the time
that the SCP Foundation was formed three
distinct timelines were generated given
the anomalous nature of the
organization's founder each of these
timelines drastically altered the nature
of SCP 001 featuring a different version
in each one in the first commonly known
as timeline HC where the foundation is
run by a high command SCP 001 was an
anomalous human corpse this timeline's
SCP 001 still exhibited all the
behavioral characteristics of a normal
human being but could additionally
replicate itself at an erratic
uncontrollable rate usually when
performing tasks that could have
multiple possible outcomes SCP 001 in
Timeline HC also interacted
anachronistically with its environment
passing through solid matter that
predated it or would Outlast it so it
had to be contained in a room that was
constructed before it existed as an
anomaly this timeline's SCP 001 was
respons responsible for conceiving the
idea for the SCP Foundation and was able
to promote a significant interest in the
organization however they were
assassinated before the foundation was
officially codified with the culprits
being a version of mobile task force Alp
zero who are believed to have originated
from either of the other two timelines
while this seems to have been done to
deter the foundation forming in this
timeline it seems to have had the
opposite effect despite the
assassination of SCP 001 occurring
before the the official formation of the
SCP Foundation in Timeline HC this
version of the foundation was
successfully codified by the 13 members
of what they refer to as high command
given the anomalous circumstances around
the death of SCP 001 it provided a
catalyst for the organization to
immediately establish itself as this
timeline's protection against the threat
posed by anomalous entities the body of
SCP 001 was placed in the building that
had been its childhood home home
securing it somewhere that predated them
to negate their anomalous properties
this made them the first anomaly
contained by timeline hc's version of
the SCP Foundation poly garnering them
the official designation of SCP 001 so
that's the first of our three timelines
at play the events that unfold in the
second are considerably different in
this timeline timeline OC the foundation
was initially created by a different SCP
001 this entity referred to primarily as
the founder appropriately enough was a
human being known to possess anomalous
temporal abilities the founder was known
to also be immortal showing no visible
signs of aging and with a resistance to
external damage that prevented him from
being directly killed any injuries he
sustained could be healed but only at
the same rate typical of an average
human being the temporal side of his
anomalous properties pertained to
predicting the future the founder was
able to with an an inarguable level of
precision and accuracy forecast events
before they occurred his foresight it
appeared to the foundation was not
inciting these events to happen as he
predicted them however everything he
ever predicted would occur became an
inevitability impossible to delay avert
or alter through any means during the
events of timeline OC and as his
preferred nickname implies the founder
was the sole figure responsible for
establishing this version of the SCP
foundation in this course of events the
05 Council of this timeline were known
as the overseer Council it was however
while he was in the process of
establishing the organization that
things started to go arai whether he was
able to predict this occurrence or not
is unknown although it seems to have
corresponded with the MTF al0
assassination of SCP 001 in the other
timeline timeline HC in Timeline OC at
the same time as the assassination in
Timeline HC the founder began to exhibit
his anomalous temporal properties in
front of the original members of
overseer Council however it should also
be noted that there was no recorded
presence of MTF Alp zero in Timeline OC
believing the founder to be a potential
danger to the foundation they had all
helped to create the founding overseer
Council classified him as an anomalous
threat they immediately devised a set of
containment measures for the founder now
designating him as SCP 001 the first
anomaly contained by this timeline's
version of the foundation he was placed
within a standard humanoid containment
cell and given regular meals while
Personnel were forbidden to communicate
with him given his role in establishing
the foundation in this version of events
SCP 001 is naturally in favor of
containing and analyzing anomalies
however not when that includes him and
insisted that he be released according
to one of his predictions for
forthcoming events he requested to be
allowed to build a device but refused to
to elaborate on the intended purpose of
it SCP 001 even refused to allow other
members of foundation Personnel to
construct the device on his behalf for
testing purposes the third of these
timelines is referred to as timeline o
where in the leading body of the
foundation are known as OverWatch here
just like the previous iterations of its
history the description of SCP 001 and
the role in forming the SCP Foundation
differs in this timeline SCP 001 is an
anomaly that consists of two distinct
Parts the first of these is a figure not
dissimilar from the founder referred to
as SCP 00 1-1 this person is also a
functionally Immortal human who doesn't
age and can't heal rapidly from damage
SCP 01-1 also advocates for securing and
analyzing anomalies however this
includes himself as he doesn't object to
his own containment or that of the
second component of this SCP 001 known
known as SCP
001a this device is capable of
accurately calculating any and all
possible outcomes of any event that is
input into it unlike the founder who
seemed to possess a foresight able to
predict the only inevitable outcome of
the future s SCP 001a is able to account
for the possibility of multiple
potential Futures even down to
accounting for how its own predictions
could potentially influence or alter
outcomes in layman's terms at least one
of the eventual ities predicted by SC
SCP 001a will always be accurate unless
the predictions are to do with its own
future or the future of SCP
0011 in this instance the device will
always produce one of two assumptions
that are incorrect either that as
cp11 was killed after an assassination
attempt and never constructed as CP
001a but that's impossible after all SCP
001a exists it's already been made in
this timeline the other incorrect
prediction it can give is that SCP
000011 also exhibits the same anomalous
properties as the prediction machine
more akin to the founder and that SCP
001 daa was never constructed in the
first place but again that can't be
right in this timeline anyway according
to records within timeline ow their
version of the founder who is of course
as CP
0011 encountered a version of mobile
task force Alp Zero from one of the
other timelines they presented the
founder of the ow timeline with detailed
blueprints for the construction of SCP
001a the devices completion coincided
with the assassination in Timeline HC
and the corresponding anomalous incident
in Timeline OC after this point MTF Alp
zero departs from timeline ow this
version of the SCP Foundation is then
created to study the device
scp1 daa with this founder and a group
of his close friends who would become
this foundation's OverWatch following
this initial research group's discovery
of other anomalous phenomenon that
threatened the rest of society the
team's goal expanded to research
anomalies and protect the world from the
danger they posed however the rest of
the OverWatch began to age at a natural
rate while the founder didn't recognize
this he volunteered to be contained and
studied thus becoming a component of
this timeline's SCP 001 stepping back
and looking at all these timelines there
seems to be a number of marked
similarities particularly relating to
how the foundation was established and
how a figure usually the one who founded
the organization possessed anomalous
means of interacting with time and
temporality under normal circumstances
interaction between alternate timelines
should be impossible but the
preservation of information about all
three on the SCP foundation's database
has somehow enabled all three timelines
to communicate with each other through
exchanging intelligence via their own
versions of the database all three
iterations of the foundation across the
three timelines have learned that almost
all the anomalies they have encountered
since being established are exclusive to
their own timeline there are a total of
17 anomalies that have been confirmed to
exist across the three timelines but
there is a concerning factor in all this
the presence of an anachronistic
military group referring to itself as
MTF Al zero this mobile task Force's
direct involvement in the events of both
timeline HC where they assassinated SCP
001 and timeline ow where they provided
schematics for SCP
01-a raises an awful lot of questions
this MTF had to be acting on orders of
the foundation but which version in
which timeline the consensus among the
leading Committees of all three the high
command overseer Council and OverWatch
is that at some unknown date in the
future each of them will inevitably send
their own version of MTF alzero back in
time to alter the foundation's past and
in a sense they've already done it and
seen how this altered the circumstances
in order to inadvertently create the
foundation but this poses the risk of
one of these timelines overriding
another thus meaning all information
garnered by alternate iterations of the
foundation could be lost so putting
their heads together these Foundation
leading committees come to the
conclusion that they need to attempt to
merge all three times timelines and it
seems the way to do so is using the
device that timeline OC's founder wanted
to build and that timeline 's founder
was able to construct this device is how
this proposal for SCP 001 was given its
nickname the Noir box the intention of
the Noir box is to shunt all three
timelines into a stable joint path like
turning loose strands into a single
length of twine as such the leading
Committees of all three different
timelines have agreed to share their
Intel on how each of them can safely
create their own Noir boxes and all
three will be used to merge the
timelines every member of high command
the overseer Council and OverWatch sign
off on it but whether or not the plan
works is another matter the fabric of
time is delicate and one wrong move
could tear everything apart now check
out SCP 001 Noir boox proposal hated
Caesar and SCP 001 Overlord Center for
more